bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat au programme
des sénateurs ce matin l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur la réforme pénale un texte
commun aux deux assemblées qui a été
adopté le 8 juillet mais après une
longue semaine de Rude négociation et
bien c'est ce texte qui devrait être
adopté définitivement aujourd'hui dans
la matinée mettant ainsi fin au long
bras de fer entre Christiane Taubira la
ministre de la Justice et puis Manuel
Valls le Premier ministre ce texte c'est
un texte de compromis chaque assemblée
afin un pas vers l'autre ainsi la
contrainte pénale cette mesure phare du
texte qui avait été au coeur de tous les
débats et bien elle est effectivement
créée mais elle est créée dans la
version de l'Assemblée nationale
autrement dit cette peine sans
emprisonnement s'appliquera d'abord au
seul délit puni d'une peine maximale de
5 ans avant d'être généralisé en 2017 à
tous les délits alors rappelez-vous ce
n'est pas ce que souhaitait les
sénateurs il voulait la rendre
obligatoire pour une série limitative de
délits cette option elle sera examinée
dans deux ans le gouvernement s'y est
engagé et puis c'est exactement la même
chose pour la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour les mineurs qui
avaient été voté par le Sénat elle aussi
elle est reportée elle fera l'objet d'un
projet de loi qui devrait être examiné
l'année prochaine alors en contrepartie
de ces concessions et bien le Sénat
huguenko sur un certain nombre de points
ainsi les peines pour les personnes
condamnées à deux ans de prison ferme ou
alors à un an lorsqu'elles sont
récidivistes et bien c'est peine
pourront continuer à être aménagé comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
les députés eux et bien souhaité revenir
sur ses seuils autre point de concession
pour les députés le recours aux écoutes
et à la géolocalisation et bien ce
recours il sera limité au seul
infractions les plus graves comme le
souhaitait les sénateurs mais sans plus
tarder direction l'hémicycle pour suivre
l'examen de ces conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur la
réforme pénale très bonne matinée à tous
sur notre chaîne
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restantes en
discussion du projet de loi relatif à
l'individualisation des peines et à la
prévention de la récidive
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel
rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
monsieur le président
le ministre mes chers collègues
oui la Commission a réussi et nous en
réjouissons
c'était un engagement il a été tenu
et il faut en remercier les présidents
de nos deux commissions des lois de
l'Assemblée dans un turboise et
Jean-Pierre cher bien sûr au premier
chef et Dominique raimbour le rapporteur
de la femme nationale avec lequel depuis
de longs mois nous avons travaillé sur
ce texte
malgré les invectives
que je prends d'ailleurs comme des
compliments souvent
proférer par un organe de presse qui n'a
pas cessé de désinformer sur cette
question dans son éditorial dans les
articles de fonds
magistrat qui est la retraite retrouve
le courage de parler comme Monsieur
magendi ou monsieur Biger oui mais chers
collègues de la majorité vous avez eu
raison et je vous en remercie d'avoir
suivi presque complètement les
propositions de votre commission des
Lois et de son rapporteur son rapporteur
idéologue laxiste démagogues
provocateurs j'en passe et des meilleurs
je prends tout ceci comme des
compliments y compris d'avoir fondé les
syndicats de magistrature
alors le texte en question que nous
avions adopté
prolongé la loi pénitentiaire de 2009 en
effet dans ce texte pour la première
fois on définissait la prison comme
l'exception et d'ailleurs l'article 3 du
projet de loi oblige le juge à motiver
spécialement la peine de prison ferme
non aménagé y compris pour les
récidivistes
d'autre part
des propositions que vous avez votées
donnés plus de cohérence au texte
notamment sur la peine de contraintes
pénales en effet elle proposait que
cette peine soit une peine autonome pour
un certain nombre de délits notamment
des délires routiers par exemple et elle
la distingué beaucoup mieux du circuit
mise à l'épreuve
enfin les propositions que vous aviez
votées mes chers collègues proposaient
d'abroger des mesures contre lesquelles
nous étions élevés fortement dans
l'opposition je pense aux interventions
de notre collègue Robert Badinter qui
n'est plus là de Jacques mesard
d'aléanziani notamment sur la rétention
de sûreté et les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs
alors à cet instant je ne vais pas
revenir sur toutes les dispositions qui
étaient en discussion mais je vais
simplement faire le point sur un certain
nombre de désaccords importants qui
étaient sur la table de la commission
Miss paritaire et qui ont été résolus
le premier concerné je vais dans dire un
mot le champ de la contrainte pénale
ça m'a été dit comme un compliment en
commission d'expéritaire
apparemment de la commission qui n'est
pas spécifiquement de mes amis ni
politique que ni autrement
que ce que j'avais proposé avec une
certaine cohérence en effet il y avait
que certaines cohérence mes chers
collègues à dire que la peine de
contraintes pénale était une peine
totalement détachée de la peine
d'emprisonnement
et qu'on suivait ce que nous a dit lors
des auditions notamment Robert Badinter
pour ne pas le citer qu'il y aurait en
matière délictuelle trois peines la
peine de prison sur si simple plus SME
la contrainte pénale et les peines
pécuniaires ou les peines de
confiscation
ce n'est pas finalement ce qui a été
retenu et
la raison pour laquelle finalement nous
sommes ralliés à la version de
l'Assemblée nationale et que cette peine
de contraintes pénale pour quelques
délits d'étagés de la peine
emprisonnement aurait été applicable
immédiatement et que donc paraît-il ça
aurait surchargé les deux applications
dispenses et les et les
personnels de probation
je remarque que cet argument était un
peu fallacieux madame la ministre
puisque vous nous proposez aujourd'hui
un amendement numéro 20 qui d'ailleurs
posé problème de coordination important
mais nous ne pourrons pas les régler ici
malheureusement et qui prévoit
l'application immédiate de la contrainte
pénale donc si l'application est
immédiate pour tout elle aurait pu être
également pour les quelques exceptions
avec des quelques dédiés que je
proposais mais la CMP en a ainsi décidé
le deuxième point concerner le seuil
pour l'aménagement des peines alors là
mes chers collègues ne veut pas être
plus long vous savez les allées est venu
qui ont eu lieu pour ma part et comme je
disais tout à l'heure dans la suite de
la loi pénitentiaire du 24 novembre 2009
qui était rapporté par notre collection
René Le Cerf nous sommes battent nous
sommes battus pour maintenir le seuil
défini par cette loi parce que il avait
été adopté ici très largement parce que
le Sénat
dans les années antérieures avaient
maintenu ce seuil malgré je dirais et
ceci grâce au président de la commission
des lois de l'époque jean-jacques-est et
que c'était cohérent avec l'ensemble du
texte donc la commission orbite
paritaire a maintenu la version adoptée
par le Sénat et je m'en félicite
troisième point
le désaccord qui concerne et non pas le
gouvernement et les assemblées mais
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat ça
concernait un certain nombre de
dispositions introduites nationales
notamment par le rapporteur Dominique
Raimbourg qui visait à accroître de
façon importante et prérogative de la
police et de la gendarmerie
ici j'avais proposé de supprimer ces
quatre articles et de modifier largement
le quatrième
en commission mixparitaire pour arriver
à un accord global
nous avons négocié sur ces articles
l'article 15 qui propose de permettre la
géolocalisation et l'intersection des
communications pour les personnes
soupçonnées d'avoir violé une
interdiction ou une obligation qui l'ont
été faites nous avions nous avons
présenté un amendement commun qui
rétablit le système mais de façon mieux
encadrée en fixant un seuil de gravité
et une finalité à la mesure pour
respecter les dispositions notamment du
Conseil constitutionnel
le Sénat avait supprimé les articles 15
bis et qu'insters l'article 15 bis a
toujours été supprimé quant à l'article
15h il a été rédigé en soumettant au
juge l'accord pour la transaction
possible par les officiers
et enfin l'article 15 squataire a été
conservé dans la rédaction du Sénat qui
en a restreint je dirais son champ et
qui également
nous paraît plus conforme à ce qu'il est
possible
ces articles sont conservés après les
débaillères à l'Assemblée nationale
quatrième point de désaccord
c'était
la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels des mineurs qui avait été
introduite dans le texte par votre
commission des Lois
cette question a fait l'objet d'un
désaccord profond
entre le gouvernement et
le Parlement même si à l'Assemblée
nationale
nos collègues députés ont été plus
faibles que vous mes chers collègues de
la majorité sanatoriale
finalement
nous nous sommes ralliés je me suis
rallié
au raisonnement suivant
qui disait qu'il fallait garder à cette
à ce projet de loi dont je dirais un mot
en conclusion ça cohérence et ne pas
introduire des réformes dans la réforme
et que la suppression des tribunaux
corrections mineurs qui parvenir dessus
n'ont pas donné les résultats escomptés
dans tous les magistrats veulent la
suppression devaient figurer dans un
autre texte
cet autre texte il est prêt j'en ai eu
connaissance au cours du dernier
trimestre de l'année dernière lorsque
j'effectuais à la demande madame le
garder soit du Premier ministre une
mission sur la PJJ
il était presque on peut dire arbitré au
moins par le ministère de la justice
mais
embargo
or
la veille de la CNP le gouvernement vous
en avez tous eu connaissance à publier
un communiqué disons que s'agissant du
débat sur les tribunaux corrections les
promeneurs
le gouvernement en prend l'engagement de
proposer la suppression de ces tribunaux
correcteurs nominaires dans un texte sur
la justice des mineurs qui sera
présentée au premier semestre 2015 mes
chers collègues qui seraient encore
toujours là en 2015 j'espère que vous
vous souviendrez pour permettre au
gouvernement de tenir ses engagements et
compte tenu de cet engagement du
gouvernement sur lequel n'avons aucune
raison de ne pas croire et bien nous
avons accepté de ne pas introduire dans
le texte de cette loi pénale la
suppression des tomates correction des
mineurs qui c'est vrai concerné un autre
sujet puisque le texte en question ne
concerne pas les mineurs enfin dernier
point mais qui avait été résolu ici en
séance c'était la suppression de la
rétention de sûreté
alors en commission des lois lors de la
première réunion vous aviez suivi votre
rapporteur fait la commission des lois
et la rétention de sûreté non pas la
surveillance de sûreté
en deuxième commission il y a eu
quelques hésitations
quelques renoncements coupables à mon
avis et finalement ici
en séance et bien l'amendement de
qui rétablissait la rétention de sûreté
a été adoptée
il a été adopté mais j'ai retenu tout de
même les déclarations de madame la
ministre
qui nous a dit que comme pour les
tribunaux corrections
cette disposition concernée des
criminels
qu'il ne fallait pas brouiller déjà
c'était assez brouillé notamment dans
certains organes de presse
le texte qui ne concernait absolument
pas les criminels ni les crimes mais
uniquement les délinquants que le
gouvernement madame Lagarde est aussi la
distracteurment était hostile à cette
mesure mais que elle devait être abrogée
dans un autre texte et à un autre moment
et donc compte tenu de ces arguments en
séance chers collègues vous avez voté le
rétablissement de la rétention de sûreté
voilà quel est je dirais le résultat de
cette CMP cet accord mes chers collègues
de la majorité mais aussi de
l'opposition qui pour certains allaient
vous rallier je pense à ce texte issu de
la CMP ou ne pas vous y opposer cet
accord est un bon accord
personne n'a mangé son chapeau comme je
l'ai lu d'ailleurs personnellement je ne
porte jamais de couvre-chef et c'est une
grande loi et c'est une grande loi que
nous allons définitivement adopter
c'est un nouveau défi une nouvelle
méthode pour combattre la récidive et
donc la délinquance et donc
l'augmentation de la délinquance et pour
assurer à nos concitoyens la plus grande
sécurité qu'il réclame à juste titre de
la part des pouvoirs publics
ce texte évidemment pour qu'il réussisse
le gouvernement doit y mettre les moyens
les moyens financiers les moyens humains
indispensables à son succès il doit
mobiliser les magistrats et de mobiliser
soladinistration notamment
l'administration pénitentiaire et
au-delà et au-delà pour obtenir les
résultats attendus voilà mes chers
collègues le texte que nous allons voter
je pense que nous pouvons en être fiers
et en conclusion je voudrais rendre
hommage particulier à Madame Christiane
Taubira garder son ministre de la
Justice pour tout l'engagement la
volonté qu'elle a mis afin que ce texte
arrive au bout de sa course merci
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Madame Christiane Taubira garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
dois vous dire que je suis heureuse
d'être avec vous ce matin et de conclure
avec vous ce parcours de ce projet de
loi dans la discussion aussi bien
l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Sénat était
extrêmement riche particulièrement riche
au cinéma elle a été très très dense et
très très riche à l'Assemblée nationale
même si je sais que il y a un goût
particulier pour les querelles entre les
deux chambres et le rapporteur n'a pas
résisté
au prix d'un seul adjectif de
dire tout le bien qu'il pensait mais je
sais que tu en penses beaucoup de bien
de l'autre chambre les débats ont été
extrêmement riches à l'Assemblée
nationale ils ont été aussi ils sont
toujours de tonalité différente parce
que ce sont des chambres différentes et
que il y a des méthodes de travail et
des approches et des sensibilités
différentes
cela enrichit considérablement le
travail parlementaire cela donne
vraiment sens à la navette parlementaire
et y compris en procédure accélérée cela
permet effectivement d'aborder d'entrer
dans les textes et dans certaines
dispositions d'une façon différente et
par conséquent enrichissante pour le
texte lui-même monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez rappelé comment s'est déroulée
la CMP je veux m'autoriser en qualité de
garde des sceaux mais au nom du
gouvernement aussi a saluer la qualité
du travail mais surtout l'état d'esprit
des parlementaires qui ont participé à
cette commission mixte paritaire
commission de parité à qui a été
préparée par la qualité des débats et
par l'état d'esprit qui régnait déjà
aussi bien l'Assemblée nationale qu'au
Sénat est à l'esprit qui a été alimenté
de façon continue par les deux
rapporteurs puisque Dominique Raimbaud
et Jean-Pierre Michel travaillent
ensemble depuis plusieurs mois le Sénat
c'était d'ailleurs en pari du texte
comme souvent il le fait très en amont
par des auditions par des travaux et par
des rencontres avec l'Assemblée par des
auditions extrêmement diversifiées par
conséquent ce texte malgré un parcours
relativement réduit dans dans les
chambres du Parlement mais un parcours
long parce que je rappelle que nous
avons commencé à travailler sur ce texte
avec la conférence de consensus qui a
été installée en septembre 2012 j'ajoute
cependant que avant même la conférence
de consensus même si la méthode est
complètement inédite même si elle a été
particulièrement féconde je ne veux pas
ignorer tous les travaux qui ont été
élaborés et
avant cette conférence de consensus y
compris dans cette chambre puisque cela
fait des années que certains d'entre
vous travaillent sur ces sujets ils
m'est déjà arrivé à plusieurs reprises
du haut de cette tribune de saluer
notamment le rapport d'enquête
parlementaire de 2000 que l'on appelle
le rapport Yeste cabanais mais j'ai
participé à vos débats sur l'application
de la loi pénitentiaire donc il y a des
travaux qui ont été effectués avant
évidemment ils ont été effectués dans
les chambres du Parlement il en était
dans les universités ils ont été dans
d'autres espaces aussi où se sont
retrouvés des chercheurs des
universitaires des parlementaires des
professionnels de la justice des
militants associatifs sensibles à ces
questions donc une très grande variété
de conception de d'expérience qui se
sont mêlées qui ont produit ces
dernières années des études des analyses
qui nous ont permis et qui ont permis
justement à la conférence de consensus
un vrai succès dans la mesure où est la
plus disposer de matériaux qui avaient
déjà été construit ça a été donc une
longue maturation même si le parcours au
sein du Parlement a été plus court il
n'a pas perdu en densité mais ça a été
une longue maturation puisque le texte
est à votre disposition depuis le 9
octobre 2013 et que les auditions
multiples que vous avez conduites vous
ont permis de prendre en compte la
diversité la multiplicité des approches
des sensibilités des perceptions sur ces
sujets cet état d'esprit qui a présidé
aux travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire a permis que aujourd'hui nous
ayons un texte que j'estime vraiment de
très grande qualité je pense que il n'y
a pas là une appréciation subjective
mais une appréciation qui se vérifiera
dans le temps et il en sera rendu
crédit au parlementaire qui auront
participé le texte vous l'avez rappelé
sur les dispositions essentielles
monsieur le rapporteur ce texte a
évidemment conservé
c'est cette dispositifs structurants à
savoir la restitution de la totale
liberté d'appréciation au magistrat par
la suppression des mécanismes nous avons
créé vous avez créé cette contrainte
pénale qui s'est précisé et qui sait
enrichi justement grâce au travail
parlementaire ce qui facilitera pour les
magistrats l'appropriation de cette
peine vous avez également préciser le
dispositif de lutte résolu contre les
sorties sèches qui sont pourvoyeuses de
récidive par la libération sous
contrainte mais vous avez encore enrichi
le texte par un certain nombre d'autres
dispositions qui consolident ces trois
dispositifs très structurants et qui
élargit aussi
la dispositions pénales les normes
pénales sur des situations qui vous
tenaient à cœur depuis plusieurs années
je pense par exemple à vos initiatives
en matière de prise en compte de
l'altération du discernement monsieur
sénateur le cerf a été très très actif
sur ce point avec à la fois évidemment
une lucidité sur ce que représente
l'altération du discernement mais une
responsabilité aussi un sens de
responsabilité aussi sur l'importance de
prendre en charge ces personnes dans le
discernement est altéré qui ne tout
logiquement ne doivent pas subir la
rigueur d'une peine maximale mais qui
doivent également pouvoir bénéficier de
soins vous êtes vous avez montré un
attachement à toute une série de sujets
mais l'assemblée également par exemple
l'assemblée a été très très soucieuse et
en particulier le député Alain Tourer
très très soucieux de faire inscrire une
amélioration des conditions
d'aménagement
des peines pour les femmes enceintes il
y a dans toute une série de dispositions
ainsi qui ont été introduites et
enrichissent à la fois les normes
pénales et qui pourront permettre à la
politique pénale d'être plus efficace je
pense également à disposition qui
concerne l'incitation à la lecture dans
l'initiative venait d'un député UMP nous
avions souhaité travailler cet
amendement plus précisément grâce à vous
nous avons pu le faire et cette
disposition est désormais dans le texte
le Parlement a également voulu inscrire
dans la partie législative du code de
l'organisation judiciaire les bureaux
d'exécution des peines
c'est une bonne chose de consolider
ainsi ces bureaux qui sont nécessaires
et efficaces pour une plus grande
diligence dans l'exécution des peines
nous avons vous avez également introduit
toujours dans le code de l'organisation
des peines ces bureaux d'aide aux
victimes que nous avons créé dans tous
les tribunaux de grande instance et puis
nous avons introduit dans la loi la
justice restaurative nous le faisons en
avance par rapport à une directive la
directive victime de l'Union européenne
que nous aurons à transposer d'ici à la
fin de l'année 2016 mais vous savez que
au-delà même
avant cette transposition et au-delà
même de l'inscription dans la loi de
cette justice restaurative nous avons
mis en œuvre depuis janvier 2014 une
expérimentation par anticipation des
dispositions de cette directivité et
notamment dans cette tribu dans huit
tribunaux de grande instance une
expérimentation pour en suivi
individualisé des victimes conformément
à ces normes intéressantes qui sont
contenues dans la directive
vous avez également justement dans ce
texte introduit une suramment de façon à
financer à contribuer au financement
parce que le gouvernement a augmenté
depuis la première année de 25,8% le
budget d'aide aux victimes là encore
augmenté de
7%, va encore l'augmenter pour la loi de
finance prochaine mais nous savons qu'il
faut diversifier les ressources de ce
budget et cette suramment de permet
effectivement de diversifier de
pérenniser le financement de l'aide aux
victimes autrement il y a également des
dispositions qui permettent
de saisir le jus d'application des
peines lorsque la mise à exécution d'une
peine survient plus de trois ans après
son prononcé là aussi c'est une mesure
importante parce qu'elle permet de
reconsidérer la situation de la personne
condamnée de voir s'il y a lieu
d'aménager cette peine parce que une
exécuter notamment une courte peine
exécutée dans un délai aussi important
quand même trois ans cela peut provoquer
une désocialisation si entre-temps la
situation de la personne a changé donc
vous avez introduit ces dispositions qui
sont j'allais dire supplétives mais il
n'y a aucune péjoration dans ce mot au
contraire puisque vous avez bien compris
que je considère à quelle consolide
l'armature même de cette réforme pénale
mais vous avez en commission mixte
paritaire je disais produit un travail
de très très grande qualité je veux
vraiment vraiment saluer cet état
d'esprit parce que lors des débats ici
au Sénat vous avez montré votre
attachement à certaines dispositions que
vous aviez introduite dès la commission
des lois d'ailleurs à l'initiative de
votre rapporteur vous aviez argumenté
donc montrer votre attachement à à ces
dispositions et donc d'avoir accepté
soit de lait aménager soit de les
différer prouve à quel point vous avez
accompli des formes pour faire réussir
cette commission mixte paritaire et
aboutir aujourd'hui à cette lecture
conclusive donc je veux vous exprimer ma
gratitude qui est une gratitude
personnelle bien entendu qui est une
gratitude politique et institutionnelle
au titre des responsabilités qui
m'improbe mais qui est une gratitude
j'allais presque dire démocratique et
civique au sens où le souci que vous
avez montré d'aboutir avec ce texte de
loi nous permettra de passer à une
application des règles pénales et à une
politique publique pénale dont nous
voulons assurer l'efficacité et c'est
efficacité elle se traduit tout
simplement par la réduction de la
récidive pas seulement par la lutte
contre la récidive mais aussi par la
prévention donc la réduction de la
récidive donc la diminution d'acte de
délinquance donc la diminution du nombre
de victimes exposées potentiellement à
ses actes de délinquance donc nous
avions une certaine effectivement
impatience pour pouvoir appliquer ces
nouvelles normes et mesurer aussi vite
que possible je l'espère les résultats
de cette prévention de la récidive de
cette lutte contre la sortie siège de
ces efforts pour la réinsertion des
personnes condamnées
vous avez accompli ces efforts sur la
contrainte pénale puisque vous aviez
introduit une contrainte pénale pour un
certain nombre de délits sans
possibilité d'incarcération vous l'avez
dit à la tribune monsieur le rapporteur
il y a il y a une logique incontestable
à considérer que l'on peut concevoir le
système des peines autour de
l'incarcération de la mande faite si on
va comme ça de l'amande de la contrainte
pénale peine autonome en milieu ouvert
et de l'incarcération et cela va
contribuer évidemment à la cohérence
cela va contribuer à l'efficacité y
compris à l'efficacité de
l'incarcération puisque l'incarcération
est prononcée pour une durée déterminée
qu'il faut prévoir aussi dans ces cas-là
la réinsertion donc préparez à
l'intérieur de la prison préparer le
retour dans la société pour que le
condamner ne soit pas en situation
objective de récidive en tout cas de
facilitation de vous y étiez très
attaché
je suis attachée aussi à cette cohérence
parce que nous avons bien vu que sur ces
dernières années la centaine de
modifications du droit pénal et de la
procédure pénale en produit une relative
incohérence dans la hiérarchie des
peines et qu'il y a lieu de travailler
cette hiérarchie des peines et que la
hiérarchie des peines doit être doit
correspondre à
la hiérarchie des valeurs de la
République c'est à dire qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de déconnexion entre
l'échelle des peines et l'échelle de nos
valeurs pour illustrer les choses très
clairement je dirais que on ne peut pas
dans une société qui est si sensible à
l'individu à la personne humaine à la
dignité de la personne humaine accepter
que les atteintes au bien soit puni plus
sévèrement que les atteintes aux
personnes il y a donc des discordances
qui nous faudra corriger et il faudra il
faudra donc à l'intérieur du code pénal
pour percevoir toutes ces discordances
et rétablir à la connexion avec nos
valeurs républicaines qui disent que la
personne est plus importante que les
biens même si le droit de propriété est
un droit constitutionnel qui doit être
protégé dans la société que nous devons
éveiller qu'il y a donc lieu de
sanctionner lorsqu'il y a atteinte au
bien mais que un des messages de la
République à l'ensemble de la société
c'est que nous sommes plus attentifs
encore à l'intégrité des personnes et
que nous punissons plus sévèrement les
atteintes aux personnes il y a donc ce
travail de fond à faire dans le code
pénal ce travail de fond je l'ai confié
à la mission côte vous le savez présidé
par Bruno cote il y a des travaux
parlementaires d'ailleurs des gens en
cours il y a des travaux de la sienne
cdH aussi sur ces sujets donc nous
allons faire en sorte que tous ces
travaux aboutissent la mission code doit
remettre son rapport à la fin de l'année
2015 de façon à ce que nous repentions
effectivement la hiérarchie des peines
et que nous la remettions en cohérence
avec que l'échelle de nos valeurs donc
cette conception est tout à fait fondée
il y a simplement le fait que il est
prématuré par rapport au travail de fond
qu'il y a accomplir il est prématuré de
le faire dans ce texte là vous avez
accepté également de modifier ce que
vous aviez inscrit dans le texte en
matière de sanction de l'inobservation
des obligations et des interdictions
vous avez accepté que ce soit le juge
correctionnel qui définissent la durée
maximale
d'incarcération qui peut être prononcé
après par le juge délégué qui serait
éventuellement saisi par le juge
d'application des peines et qui pourrait
être décider une mise en oeuvre
partielle de l'incarcération parce que
nous savons que les parcours de
résistance peuvent être des parcours
chaotiques qui a des moments parfois où
il faut resserrer encore le contrôle et
la sanction il y a des moments où au
contraire on sent que la personne est en
cours de réinsertion et qu'il faut
assouplir donc il fallait donner ses
possibilités avec un délit spécifique
donc séparé
nous avions une difficulté possible
c'était celle de la nécessité
d'introduire de nouvelles poursuites
donc de risquer de faire suspendre la
contrainte pénale c'est-à-dire toutes
les mesures de suivi c'était prendre un
risque sur l'efficacité de la mesure
vous avez consenti à introduire cette
modification et je veux vous en
remercier vous avez accepté également en
CMP que les services pénitentiaires
d'insertion de probation
soit reconnu dans leur mission
régaliennes et qui soit pilote de la
mise en oeuvre de la contrainte pénale
ce qui bien entendu ne préjugue pas
l'inaltère pas leur relation avec les
partenaires associatifs parce que les
associations interviennent en
pressentiel qu'elles font un travail de
très grande qualité un travail
professionnel qui est reconnu mais pour
la mise en oeuvre de la contrainte
pénale qui est une peine autonome une
peine en soi en milieu ouvert une peine
réelle qui d'ailleurs par l'article 8 de
la loi modifié l'article 131-3 du code
pénal et inscrit bien la contrainte
pénale après l'emprisonnement avant
l'amende et les autres peines de milieu
ouvert donc il s'agit bien d'une peine
autonome qui n'est pas référencée à la
prison en dehors évidemment du de la
disposition que je viens d'évoquer mais
qui est vraiment une peine en milieu
ouverte sa mise en oeuvre doit être rég
européenne parce que il s'agit
effectivement des missions du ministère
de la Justice donc merci de l'avoir fait
je répète cela une alternant rien le
travail qui est produit par les
associations vous avez tenu à revenir
évidemment à la loi pénitentiaire ce que
l'on peut comprendre
aussi bien pour des raisons de droit que
pour des raisons de Constance parce que
nul n'ignore le travail de fond qui a
été accompli sur cette loi pénitentiaire
dans le rapporteur était Jean-René le
CEF et le président de la commission des
lois de d'alors très très actif monsieur
le Président yest vous avez souhaité
rétablir ces dispositions dans le texte
là c'est la sembler nationale qui a
accompli le plat le plat le plus grand
pour rejoindre le Sénat vous avez
également modifier le régime d'octroi de
réduction de peine et de libération en
conditionnelle vous l'avez dit monsieur
le rapporteur le
a été maintenu mais enfin vous en avez
accepté l'aboutissement a été maintenu
sur des dispositions concernant la
géolocalisation et les écoutes
j'ai présenté hier soir à l'Assemblée
nationale des amendements qui ont été
rejetés par l'Assemblée nationale ce
dont je me doutais bien entendu j'ai
présenté ces amendements en disant très
clairement au député que je souhaitais
les alerter sur les risques
constitutionnels que l'on m'indiquait
sur ces dispositions
je suis pas certaine que ces risques
n'existaient pas il me paraît
responsable de la part du gouvernement
d'alerter les députés et les sénateurs
sur ces risques potentiels
merci monsieur le Président yes parce
que un député du MP a essayé de me
chercher querelle sur ses amendements
hier soir j'en profite pour dire que ce
sont des amendements qui sont souhaités
qui sont souhaité également par le
ministère de l'Intérieur et
l'Assemblée nationale ayant repoussé ses
amendements le gouvernement ne peut pas
vous les présenter mais voilà il y avait
sur la géolocalisation sur les écoutes
sur la généralisation de la surveillance
judiciaire il y avait donc il y a dans
le texte quand même quelques
dispositions qui nous autorisent à
craindre éventuellement même si le texte
n'était pas déféré aux conseils
constitutionnel une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité intervenant après
pourraient éventuellement mais bon voilà
le débat a été a eu lieu hier soir à
l'Assemblée nationale
je n'irai pas plus loin parce que vous
avez présenté l'essentiel du contenu de
cette commission mixte paritaire vous
avez terminé monsieur le rapporteur sur
la non-suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs vous avez
rappelé l'engagement du gouvernement je
rappelle qu'il s'agit bien d'un
engagement du gouvernement c'est un
engagement de la Garde des Sceaux mais
bien un engagement du gouvernement de
présenter la réforme de l'ordonnance de
1945 dans le semestre le 1er semestre
2015 c'est une marque de respect
vis-à-vis du Parlement de la part du
gouvernement que cet engagement soit
pris par le gouvernement vis-à-vis des
parlementaires pour motiver le fait que
le gouvernement ne souhaitait pas que
ces dispositions concernant les mineurs
soit inscrire inscrits dans ce texte
inscrit dans ce texte qui ne concerne
pas les mineurs voilà un dernier mot
pour vous dire à nouveau ma gratitude
pour la qualité des débats la qualité
des travaux et la qualité du texte qui
est sorti de cette commission mixte
paritaire vous dit à ma gratitude plus
longue encore pour ces deux années au
cours desquelles nous avons eu aborder
ces questions qui concernent la justice
qui concerne aussi la justice civile
parce que vous y êtes extrêmement
sensible aussi qui concerne également la
proximité de la justice sur le
territoire parce que vous êtes très très
attaché à la présence des sites
judiciaires sur les territoires et donc
à leur accessibilité pour les citoyens
ou qui se trouvent votre mobilisation
permanente et constante sur les textes
de la justice conforte le travail des
magistrats dégriffés des personnels
pénitentiaires des personnels de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse ce
n'est donc pas la seule gratitude de la
Garde des Sceaux et du gouvernement que
j'exprime devant vous c'est bien la
gratitude de l'ensemble de ceux qui font
vivre ce beau service public de la
justice
dans la discussion générale la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Sueur président de la commission des
lois
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
il vous a fallu madame la ministre
beaucoup de ténacité de courage
d'obstination de volonté
pour arriver à ce 17 juillet
et à ce jour où nous l'espérons sera
voté
cette réforme pénale
que vous avez menée
malgré les critiques
les caricatures
les insultes
avec beaucoup de force
et aussi
un sens du dialogue et de l'écoute
qui doit être souligné
il est rare je pense même qu'il est sans
précédent
qu'un texte de loi de cette importance
soit précédé
d'une concertation qui a duré 18 mois
avec d'abord un groupe de travail
présidé par Madame à estrachi
puis
cette grande conférence de consensus
au cours de laquelle tout le monde s'est
exprimé
tous les professionnels de la justice
les magistrats les avocats les greffiers
tous les personnels les représentants de
l'administration pénitentiaire les
représentants de la police de la
gendarmerie et toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ont participé à ces deux jours
en ont été marqués
on a aussi entendu les détenus on a
aussi bien sûr entendu les victimes
et puis il y a eu la grande conférence
qui a eu lieu ensuite à l'Unesco
le sens de la justice
son but son efficacité les attentes de
nos citoyens
cela est un parcours
tout à fait remarquable je le redis sans
précédent pour préparer
ce texte de loi
ensuite je voulais mes chers collègues
rendre hommage vous le comprendrez à mon
collègue et ami Jean-Pierre Michel
pourquoi parce que je lisais ces
jours-ci vous savez que c'est une très
vieille littérature elle est ancienne
comme le Sénat
beaucoup d'articles sur ce thème
finalement à quoi sert le Sénat
le Sénat
sert de manière éminente parce que sans
bicamérisme il n'y a pas d'écriture de
la loi il n'y a pas de navette il n'y a
pas ce travail collectif qui fait que
peu à peu la loi c'est la mort mot après
mot phrase après phrase et je crois que
le Sénat
il démontre son existence quand on son
saint on entend des paroles fortes et
c'est pourquoi je veux rendre hommage à
Jean-Pierre Michel parce que nous avons
la conviction j'ai la conviction que le
rapport qu'a présenté Jean-Pierre Michel
était totalement fidèle à l'esprit de la
loi qu'il en tirait les conséquences
qu'il disait avec netteté
pourquoi cette loi a été faite quel
était l'objectif attendu pourquoi il
fallait une nouvelle définition de la
peine un sens de la peine pourquoi il
fallait de nouvelles peines bien définie
et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu aussi cher
Jean-Pierre Michel les caricatures vous
avez répondu avec beaucoup de talents
c'est vrai qu'elle vous honore en un
sens
vivre c'est lutter disait Victor Hugo et
il avait bien raison de le dire et je
crois que le Sénat est fort quand il y a
des paroles fortes qui s'énoncent en son
sein ce fut très souvent le cas beaucoup
plus qu'on ne le dit
et
nous sommes honorés d'avoir eu un
rapporteur qui a défendu comme vous
l'avez fait madame la ministre l'esprit
de cette loi
alors la commission mixte paritaire a
réussi
vous savez dans quelles conditions
les conditions ont été celles d'un
dialogue parfois sans concession parfois
difficile avec
des demandes des exigences des compromis
mais des points auxquels nous étions
profondément attachés
je veux en citer trois d'abord la
contrainte pénale est une vraie peine
notre rapporteur avait proposé que cette
peine fut la seule possible pour un
certain nombre de délits ce ne sera pas
le cas nous avons fait un accord avec
l'Assemblée nationale mais la question
reviendra
au bout d'un certain nombre d'années
prévues dans la loi il y aura
l'extension à tous les délits et la
question sera posée de savoir s'il ne
faut pas reprendre cette idée c'est une
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
deuxièmement et vous avez cité le
travail accompli précédemment
particulier par Jean-René Lecerf
nous étions profondément
extrêmement attaché à ce qu'on ne revint
pas sur ce qui a été décidé lors du vote
de la loi pénitentiaire et sur les
aménagements de peine pour les non
récidivistes et pour les récidivistes
nous savons bien cela nous a été assidu
qui lui un arbitrage c'est comme ça que
l'on dit il y a quelques temps
mais nous considérons que le Parlement
doit faire la loi et nous considérons
que le fait que le Sénat est unanimement
voté ces aménagements de peine
le fait que le vote unanime était
renouvelé il y a quelques semaines ici
étaient des arguments forts et puissants
et il y a un accord le gouvernement a
marqué aussi son accord c'est très
important pour ces aménagements de peine
pourquoi et bien vous le savez tout le
monde le sait il y a dans cette loi une
volonté d'en finir avec les sorties
sèches finir avec les sorties sèches en
finir avec les sorties sèches cela veut
dire aménager la sortie de prison la
préparer faire qu'un individu après 6 7
8 10 ans en détention ne se retrouve pas
un matin sur le trottoir sans milieu
familial sans milieu social sans
logement sans travail et puis voilà
et alors
et bien nous voulons que la prison qui
est une institution nécessaire et forte
de la République d'ailleurs madame la
ministre je vous réjouis que vous veniez
inaugurer très bientôt une prison dans
le département du Loiret signe que nous
voulons des établissements
pénitentiaires qui sont des institutions
nécessaires de la République et qui ont
trois missions protéger la société punir
et préparer la réinsertion ces trois
missions sont absolument indispensables
et donc c'est une dimension très
importante de cette loi que de préparer
la sortie de prison il lui faudra des
moyens et je sais que surtout les
banques comme on dit encore il n'y a pas
beaucoup de bancs et bien nous serons
très vigilants sur les moyens qui sont
naturellement indispensables enfin il y
a notre point auquel nous étions très
attachés
et madame la ministre vous savez mieux
que personne
combien il fallut quelques fois discuter
convaincre pour parvenir à se
communiquer que vous avez bien voulu
publier
lundi à 17h alors que la commission
mixte paritaire se déroulait le mardi à
10h30
par rapport à la question de la justice
des mineurs
envers et contre tout envers et contre
le démagogie et les polémiques nous
considérons que les mineurs sont des
êtres en devenir nous sommes fidèles à
l'ordonnance de 45 même s'il a été
changé 37 fois parce que c'est un texte
qui peut toujours être amélioré et nous
considérons que c'est un engagement
important très fort de votre part madame
la ministre et de la part de l'ensemble
du gouvernement vous le venez de le dire
à cette tribune
qu'il y aura un débat sur un projet de
loi pendant le premier semestre de
l'année 2015 sur la justice des mineurs
et les tribunaux correctionnels des
mineurs
qui ont suivi cette question et aussi à
Matignon et également à la présidence de
la République je tiens le dire chacun se
reconnaîtra bon pour finir tout à fait
mes chers collègues je dirais que cette
date du 17 juillet 2014
l'histoire dira que penser de cela
mais pourrait représenter une date
importante dans l'histoire de notre
justice
parce que la philosophie de cette loi
c'est de rompre avec le tout carcéral
c'est de dire que nous voulons
l'impunité et pour qu'il y ait impunité
qui est demandé à juste titre par tous
les citoyens par toutes les victimes il
faut une diversité de peine et il faut
des peines individualisées nous voulons
de la rigueur de la rigueur dans la
détention qui doit préparer la
réinsertion
de la rigueur dans la
contrainte pénale qui doit être une
vraie peine préparer accompagner et
suivi
nous voulons
nous voulons tout cela
c'est un lapsus
nous voulons madame madame la ministre
vous avez raison et je corrige nous
voulons l'impunité oui oui nous voulons
l'impunité on est d'accord
bon
j'ai dit
voilà bon ça marche
alors on est tous d'accord puisqu'on est
d'accord sur les mots vous savez que
c'est très important les mots madame la
ministre c'est pas vous que je vais dire
cela alors puisqu'on est d'accord sur
les mots il me reste à vous dire merci à
vous tous qui avait contribué à
l'élaboration de ce texte qui je le
redis sera un changement je l'espère
dans notre culture par rapport à la loi
pénale et par rapport à l'idée que nous
nous faisons de la justice dans ce pays
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jacques mesard
pour le groupe RDC
monsieur le président
madame la garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues notre groupe ne veut pas
l'impunité pour les délinquants monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
nous avons l'habitude d'être cohérent
madame Benbassa ça commence très mal
j'espère que c'était un lapsus
le vrai le vrai débat la question de
fond qui
ressurgit constamment depuis de longues
années c'est que nos prisons sont
surpeuplés dans des conditions qui sont
absolument détestables et intolérable
par rapport aux valeurs qui sont celles
de tous ceux qui sont ici et qu'en même
temps en même temps on sait bien que par
rapport à d'autres propos qui ont pu
être tenir tenus dans certains journaux
ou à l'Assemblée nationale dire il faut
construire illico 20 000 places de plus
et d'une ce n'est pas possible et de
deux ça ne résoudra pas le problème
voilà quelle est la réalité de fond et
voilà ce qui certainement vous a amené
avec d'autres arguments madame la
ministre a proposé ce texte alors
le tout carcéral nous le savons a
longtemps été présenté comme la solution
universelle à tous les mots de la
délinquance
le projet de loi qui avait été amendé
par le Sénat je crois redonner un fil
d'Ariane à notre politique pénale dans
le labyrinthe législatif dans lequel
elle s'était souvent perdue
chers rapporteur
vous avez parlé des attaques que vous
avez subies attaquant juste
je sais pas si on peut vous pardonner le
fait d'avoir contribué à la création du
syndicat de la magistrature mais pour le
reste je ne puis que louer vos qualités
mais je crois quand même que à défaut
d'avoir Valé votre chat pot vous avez
quand même avalé pas mal de couleurs
nous nous avons refusé la rétention de
sûreté
les peines planches notre groupe avait
d'ailleurs déposé deux propositions de
loi sur ces sujets et nous avions aussi
souvent contesté les lois pénales
réactives aux médias et ça ce n'est pas
du laxisme de dire cela c'est simplement
un attachement aux valeurs fondamentales
de la République
donc comme un accord sur ce texte les
peines blanchies ont été supprimées
comme la révocation automatique des
sursis pour les récidivistes déjà plus
lourdement condamnés
en ce qui concerne la contrainte pénale
mesure phare de ce texte elle a été
conservée dans la version de l'Assemblée
nationale
mais cette version
nous
nous l'avons nous quand même un peu
apprécié
le texte qui nous est aujourd'hui
proposé
une commission mixité monsieur le
président de la commission des lois vous
considérez que à partir du moment où
elle conclut c'est une réussite et nous
connaissons votre enthousiasme constant
pour tous ces grands succès mais
ce texte a perdu de la cohérence qui lui
avait été donnée lors de l'examen par le
Sénat nous avions prévu que la
contrainte pénale devenait la peine
principale pour une liste limitative de
délits excluant les atteintes aux
personnes notre assemblée dans sa grande
sagesse
pourrions dire aux députés qui nous
qualifient de majorité ringarde que nous
n'avons guère de leçons à recevoir deux
en la matière
et bien notre assemblée avait estimé
qu'il fallait avant son extension à tous
les délits en 2017 suscité à nouveau
débat autour de son évaluation
dans sa version actuelle cette
contrainte pénale pourrait
s'apparenter à une énième sanction
pénale parmi les innombrables autres qui
existent déjà dans l'arsenal juridique
madame la garde des sceaux vous aviez
raison de poser le problème de la
hiérarchisation les sanctions c'est un
vrai problème et aussi de leur cohérence
avec l'organisation judiciaire et ce
débat il pourra pas être reculé trop
trop longtemps c'est un véritable
problème l'option choisie
aboutit à une peine en milieu ouverte
plus contraignante que le sursis avec
mise à l'épreuve qui n'est pas supprimée
pour un panel de délit moins grave je ne
suis d'ailleurs pas sûr qu'elle sera
appliquée par les juges tant du fait de
son manque de lisibilité qu'en raison
surtout et nous le savons tous du manque
de moyens financiers humains les
gouvernements successifs quels qu'ils
soient persistent et signes dans des
réformes qui sont parfois trop
superficielles hors de la réalité pénale
je l'ai dit surpopulation carcérale
désocialisation des petits délinquants
inefficacité des processus d'insertion
et de réinsertion inexécution des peines
qui est aussi l'un des gros gros
problèmes de notre système actuel et au
bout de cela épuisement des
professionnels
le texte issu de la commission x
paritaire a rétabli une disposition
supprimée par la Haute Assemblée
confiant aux officiers de police
judiciaire au pouvoir de transiger sur
certaines infractions sur le modèle
anglo-saxon quelle est la le signal
envoyé à nos concitoyens quel est ce
mauvais mélange de genre qui ne respecte
pas les prérogatives de l'autorité de
poursuite qu'incarne le procureur de la
République
nous regrettons que l'on aille vers de
telles dispositions au mépris des grands
principes de notre droit pénal à ce
titre il était essentiel que le suivi
pénitentiaire des personnes placées sous
suivie judiciaire reste une prérogative
des spips et ne soit pas partagé avec
des acteurs non régaliens à la
légitimité plus que floue
le gouvernement
s'est engagé à déposer au début de
l'année 2015 et vous l'avez rappelé un
texte portant réforme de l'ordonnance de
1945 la commission mix paritaire n'a pas
conservé la disposition introduite par
le Sénat qui supprimait les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs nous le
regrettons donc acte je rappelle aussi
que c'était un engagement de campagne du
président de la République mais il y en
a qui sont tenus ceux qui posent
problème et ceux qui ne sont pas tenus
qui devraient être tenus mais ça c'est
un autre débat vous le savez
ces formations posent plus de
difficultés qu'elles n'ont résolvent
aujourd'hui et je suis heureux que vous
ayez annoncé que on reviendra sur dans
quelques mois sur ces textes donc le
texte que nous à présent à voter qui
doit être devrait être le symbole du
refus du populisme pénal qui a trop
longtemps présidé à l'élaboration de la
politique pénale
nous souhaitons qu'il ne devienne pas
madame la garde des sceaux un simple
texte d'opportunité et qu'il reçoive une
application forte
vous voulez aussi faire un cavalier par
rapport à ce débat nous avons entendu
j'en ai pour 10 secondes les
déclarations du ministre Montebourg sur
les professions réglementées il serait
il serait important madame garde des
sceaux que vous puissiez rassurer au
moins la profession des avocats et en
particulier dans les petits et moyens
barreaux parce que ce sont eux qui
assument souvent la charge de la défense
pénale et c'est aussi important de ne
pas les fragiliser encore plus que ce
n'est le cas actuellement dans ces
conditions
la majorité de mon groupe apportera son
soutien à ce texte et approuvera les
conclusions de la CMP je vous remercie
par la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Esther ben bassin
pour le groupe écologique
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mais chers
collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui le texte de
la Commission comme vous le savez de la
commission mix paritaire sur le projet
de Loire relative à l'individualisation
des peines et à la prévention de la
récidive je veux le dire d'emblée je
saurais pas je serai un peu moins
critique bien sûr que Monsieur mesard ce
texte est une source de grande
satisfaction pour le groupe écologiste
d'une part parce qu'il constitue un
véritable tournant pour la justice de
notre pays
en effet sans éluder la souffrance et la
place des victimes ni céder un
quelconque laxisme il a sort de
véritable alternatives à l'un quartier
ration dont on sait que les biens
souvent à l'origine de la récidive la
contrainte pénale disposition phare du
projet de loi qui se déroulera en milieu
ouvert est un signe peine à part entière
une peine dont la finalité de
responsabiliser et de rincérer le
condamné dans notre société nous
souhaitons d'ailleurs avec force que
cette nouvelle peine trouver rapidement
toute sa place dans le système pénal
qu'elle soit véritablement appliquée et
ne soit pas considéré par les magistrats
comme une simple alternative au sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve
d'autre part parce qu'un élève Boran un
véritable texte de gauche le Sénat a
montré une fois de plus qu'il était
capable non seulement d'esprit de
consensus mais aussi d'ambition et de
liberté
le succès de la commission mixte
paritaire était nécessaire à ce que les
avancées introduites par le Sénat soit
maintenu et défendu cela a été le cas et
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
nous faire preuve d'équilibre
je veux ici saluer votre travail madame
la garder sceaux votre ténacité et votre
engagement au service de cette réforme
ambitieuse nous regrettons bien entendu
que la suppression des tribunaux
collectionnels pour mineur adopté à
l'initiative des écologistes et de notre
rapporteur n'est pas été maintenu mais
nous nous félicitons de l'engagement
pris de la présentation au premier
semestre 2015 on compte sur vous d'un
projet de loi de réforme de la justice
des mineurs et nous serons vigilants
quant à la tenue de cet engagement
si nous déplorons également l'abandon de
certaines mesures comme l'abrogation de
la rétention de sûreté que nous
appelions de nos vœux nous partageons
bien l'esprit de cette belle réforme en
premier lieu le rétablissement d'une
véritable individualisation des peines
qui passaient par la suppression des
mécanismes entravant la liberté
d'appréciation des juges
il est
temps
ça arrive quand même
bon il était temps mes chers collègues
de mettre fin
bon écoutez
je suis contente du loi vous voyez un
peu
ah c'est les mesures je vous ai mis
il était temps mes chers collègues de
médecin c'est aberration que sont les
peines plancher
ainsi qu'à la révocation automatique
du durcissant et du souci avec mise à
l'épreuve
au groupe écologique nous ne sommes ni
dans l'idéologie ni dans l'angélisme
voilà
vous allez un peu vous taire quand même
pour que je finisse mon sexe
madame
voulez-vous repartez et puis vous
revenez ensuite je laisse passer le
rateur et
je vais appeler monsieur Jean-Jacques
Yester la tribune s'il veut bien le
temps que Madame Benbassa reprenne ses
savoirs
monsieur le Président madame le garde
des sceaux on est désolé pour me la même
Bassard on va lui donner du miel du
Gâtinais
faut lui donner du miel du Gâtinais
monsieur le Président sueur de la région
Centre isolée
pour l'instant
ça va devenir la plus petite région de
France et quand même formidable avant il
y avait les Limousin mais
chers collègues donc nous avons assisté
avec un grand intérêt
à la CMP qui a adopté le projet de loi
relatif à l'individualisation des peines
et renforçant l'égalité et l'efficacité
des sanctions pénales puisque c'est
comme ça qu'elle s'appelle maintenant
madame le garde des sceaux je peux leur
dire quand même et vous l'avez évoqué
une navette aurait été préférable parce
que sur un certain nombre de sujets que
je vais évoquer et notamment sur ce
problème de la géolocalisation et et le
suivi il y a quand même un petit
problème même après le texte de CMP
franchement et je persiste à penser que
le Sénat avait eu raison la commission
des lois avait eu raison de supprimer
cette dispositif après il a été rétabli
on a essayé de l'encadrer mais ça ne me
paraît pas suffisant
alors selon moi la est-ce que j'ai
entendu des sorties sèches etc tout un
tome de problématiques il suffirait
d'appliquer avec tous les moyens
nécessaires la loi pénitentiaire
c'est quand même extraordinaire on a
voté une loi qui prévoyait que la prison
ne soit pas uniquement
enfermé des gens et ensuite et laisser
sans mais l'insertion la réinsertion ça
doit commencer nous l'avons dit nous
l'avons répété que en cas
d'alcarcération ça doit être le premier
jour de l'enfermement que doit commencer
la réinsertion et il y a le travail vous
vous mettez des dispositions sur la
lecture tout ça c'est très bien mais en
fait on ne l'a pas appliqué le
gouvernement précédent qui l'avait fait
voter et depuis deux ans on peut pas
considérer que les choses ont vraiment
progressé dans ce domaine alors c'est ça
alors ajoutons que la prison ça continue
à être la cour des miracles et oui alors
on mélange des grands délinquants qui
sont en attente de placement dans un
établissement pour peine avec des
détenus provisoires les maisons d'arrêt
qui qui devrait pas être ça si on trouve
pas des moyens je peux vous dire que
toute façon en grande partie on aura
loupé une nouvelle réforme qui ne
changera strictement rien
voilà donc
mais c'est pour ça que on a voulu
inventer la contrainte pénale on a
l'impression que
non mais
quand on quand on a cru à quelque chose
et qu'on y croit toujours franchement je
me demande pourquoi on fait une nouvelle
réforme qu'on appliquera pas plus que
les autres
voilà mais non madame le garder son j'ai
quand même une certaine expérience de la
de du fonctionnement de la justice
maintenant et là pour moi bon et donc on
prend des mesures qui sont peut-être
utiles pour simplement diminuer
l'enfermement mais pas la récidive en
plus c'est pas ça la question je crois
alors la contrainte pénale moi je
considère qu'elle est un peu dans la
confusion
car c'est une peine alternative à
l'emprisonnement
dans sa conception initiale
non pas tout à fait justement on va y
venir et le juge pouvait donc choisir de
recourir soit une peine d'emprisonnement
ou à la contrainte pénale et c'est quand
même une sorte de super sur si avec les
années preuve
applicable tant par le juge de la peine
que par Jules d'application des peines
ce dispositif avait été approuvé par
l'Assemblée nationale moyennant une
évolution dans le temps
souhaitant en faire une peine autonome
et moi je le salue la logique de notre
rapporteur parce qu'il faut le saluer je
l'ai dit je le répète il y a une logique
le Sénat oui mais attendez ça veut pas
dire je suis d'accord avec lui
attendez je vais dire mais quand même
bon le Sénat est circonscrit
l'application de la contrainte pénale au
seul je le dépeine pour bien marquer le
caractère autonome de cette nouvelle
peine
en prévoyant par ailleurs de remplacer
pour certains délits la peine de prison
par la contrainte pénale mais on a bien
vu que c'était un peu une impasse vous
aviez mis le vol vous l'avez supprimé
ce qui démontre bien qui restait
quelques délits quelques délits très
mineures et donc on voit bien la limite
de de l'exercice et madame le garde des
sceaux vous avez tout à l'heure évoqué
la bien des grandes différences entre
les atteintes au bien et les atteintes
aux personnes moi je vais vous dire
quand même je connais un je pense que
tout se connaissent cet exemple
quand une personne âgée se fait
cambrioler qu'on a vidé sa maison qu'on
l'a complètement bouleversé c'est le
viol de son intimité et c'est
extrêmement traumatisant pour les
personnes c'est pratiquement même s'il y
a pas d'agression même si c'est en leur
absence c'est vraiment un traumatisme
qui est extrêmement profond c'est pour
ça que il faut pas faire trop de
comparaison absolue moi je trouve que
c'est c'est quelquefois extrêmement
traumatisant pour les victimes voilà
non mais je dis pas que c'est pas grave
je dis pas que c'est pas grave mais
quand même le cambriolage le cambriolage
comme ça doit être sanctionné sévèrement
plus qu'un vol comme ça ordinaire voilà
bon la CMP donc n'a pas fait de la
contrainte pénale une pelle autonome se
substitue à la prison
pour autant on ne peut pas nier quand
lui-même le dispositif finalement adopté
n'est pas espurgée tout ambiguïté
puisque la contrainte pénale à la nature
d'une peine et l'apparence d'un
aménagement de peine je suis désolé
comment pourra-t-elle être perçue par
les délinquants comme une véritable
punition comment les juges pourront-ils
l'appliquer le beaucoup ont dit que ça
sera peu appliqué par les juges en bref
est-ce que la justice pourrait être
rendue avec cette nouvelle mesure aussi
bien qu'avant j'en doute et surtout elle
s'appliquera parce que pour l'instant
c'est l'idée de 5 ans mais à partir 2017
c'est les délits 10 ans alors là moi je
trouve que on va très vite et très fort
c'est tous les la problématique d'un
notamment de la délinquance sexuelle ce
qui ne veut pas dire qui est pas
aménagement de peine c'est autre chose
parce qu'il peut y avoir des modalités
mais quand même appliquer la contrainte
pénale je ne sais pas quelle mesure on
prendra pour ces gens-là mais enfin je
trouve que c'est vraiment excessif
je passerai rapidement sur les tribunaux
correctionnels pour enfants
je pense que Madame le gardeesseau vous
êtes engagé à faire une enfin
une réforme profonde de l'ordonnance de
45 dont on a bien dit qu'elle ait pu
l'ordonnance de 45 même si les principes
doivent être toujours respectés mais il
n'empêche que cette ordonnance
d'ailleurs quand on parle de
l'ordonnance de 45 comme un texte sacré
comme elle a été modifiée comme l'a dit
Jean-Pierre sur 37 fois je sais pas ce
qu'il en reste exactement bon donc
voilà mais je suis d'accord d'ailleurs
je l'ai dit bon alors il reste la
procédure de transaction pénale alors
j'ai exactement les mêmes les mêmes
inquiétudes que que notre ami cette
maison cette procédure de transaction
pénale par les officiers de police
judiciaire franchement alors elle est un
peu plus acceptable dans la mesure où
grâce au Sénat
grâce au Sénat c'est quand même sous
l'autorité du procureur sur autorisation
et ça doit être homologué parce que
avant franchement mais comment des
comment des parlementaires peuvent
autant
oublier la séparation des pouvoirs c'est
extraordinaire comment on peut voter au
Parlement des amendements de telle sorte
j'en dirai la même chose des écoutes
téléphoniques et à la géolocalisation le
garde des sceaux et là je crois qu'on a
pas vraiment corrigé de texte
franchement il y a un vrai problème ou
bien il y a des écoutes judiciaires ou
bien il y a des écoutes administratives
mais les écoutes administratifs sont
encadrés et ne sont pas du tout dans ce
but là
et les écoutes judiciaires elles sont
sous l'autorité du juge des libertés ou
du parquet au moins
et bien du parquet de moins en moins
compte tenu de la jurisprudence récente
de la courte cassation donc là je pense
qu'on aura un vrai problème alors voilà
en conclusion
certains nombre de correctifs qui
étaient apportés au texte voté par
l'Assemblée mais nous restons opposés la
philosophie du texte qui risque
d'envoyer un signal négatif au délin on
aurait pu évoquer aussi la cession du
procès pénal qui suscite une grande
inquiétude chez magistrats nous
n'approuvons pas la suppression des
peines plancher d'autant que paradoxe
allemand les Juifs devront au contraire
spécialement motiver
la peine de prison c'est le retournement
complet d'une philosophie et un
changement de conception de la justice
pénale et puis madame le garde des
sceaux quoi que vous en dites
comme toute réforme de la justice elle
risque de se heurter à l'absence de
moyens c'est pourquoi le groupe UMP ne
pourra voter ce texte de loi
madame Benbassa vous avez retrouvé votre
voix
elle mange du temps là
merci pour votre indulgence écouter ça
arrive à tout le monde
bon merci en tout cas
je prends la seconde moitié les auteurs
d'infraction doivent être sanctionnés
les victimes obtenir
réparation mais avant tout il faudrait
trouver le moyen de vivre ensemble dans
une société pacifiée et ce projet de loi
je le crois il contribue par le lien
social sur lequel il met l'accent si je
l'ai dit et nous regrettons les quelques
reculs du texte de la CMP par rapport à
celui issu des travaux du Sénat je veux
aujourd'hui me concentrer sur les
avancées les véritables progrès que
contient ce texte ainsi les conditions
de sortie de détention selon seront
particulièrement encadrés et ce afin de
lutter contre les sorties sèches
véritables terreaux de la récidive
priorité sera donné à la préparation de
la réinsertion des détenus aussi bien
avant qu'après la sortie de prison de
surcroît les conditions de mise en œuvre
des aménagements de peine resteront
celle inscrit dans la loi pénitentielle
et unean adoptée par notre assemblée
enfin la CMP en retenant certaines
propositions du Sénat n'a pas fait
l'économie du sort des plus fragiles de
nos concitoyens d'une part en instaurant
un mécanisme d'atténuation de peine pour
les personnes atteintes de maladies
mentales atténuation couplées avec des
obligations de soif d'autre part en
enterrant la création d'une procédure de
demande de mise en liberté pour motive
médical au bénéfice des personnes
placées en détention provisoires cette
dispositions qui reprend les termes
d'une proposition de loi écologistes
adopté à l'unanimité par le Sénat en
février dernier
dont j'ai été d'ailleurs la rapporteur
montre que le texte dont nous sommes
saisis aujourd'hui permettra d'améliorer
le droit et de combler certaines lacunes
certains vides juridiques on l'espèce il
s'agit de mettre un terme à une
inégalité de traitement personne
condamnée et prévenu en permettant
également ces dernières de bénéficier
d'une suspension de peine quand leur
état de santé est durablement
incompatible avec la détention pour
toutes les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer c'est avec conviction et
sérénité que le groupe écologiste
soutiendra ce texte et tout ce qui
contribueront à l'avenir à faire de
notre société une société plus juste et
plus inclusive je vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur Yves
de traigne pour le groupe UD
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
tel qu'elle a été présentée la loi
relative à la prévention de la récidive
et à l'efficacité des sanctions pénales
s'inscrit dans la lignée de la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 qui doit beaucoup
à notre collègue Jean-René le cerf et
qui encouragé déjà les aménagements de
peine partant du principe incontestable
me semble-t-il que la peine ne doit pas
seulement punir le délinquant et
protéger la société mais aussi tenter de
préparer une réinsertion exemple de
récidive
en mettant l'accent sur la réinsertion
du délinquant notamment au travers de la
mise en oeuvre de la contrainte pénale
qui est une nouvelle peine de probation
qui constitue si je puis dire la mesure
phare de ce texte et bien le texte
constitue en quelque sorte un
prolongement de la loi pénale mais dans
le même temps force est de constater que
les actuels conseillés d'insertion et de
probation s'occupent en moyenne chacun
de 150 à 200 mesures quand il faudrait
pour que le suivi soit réel et que la
mesure porte ses fruits se limitait à
une quarantaine ou une cinquantaine de
dossiers par conseillé dans le même
temps également nous constatons que même
à supposer que l'on parvienne à
approcher ce ratio et vous nous annoncez
je crois la création de 1000 postes
supplémentaires de conseiller
d'insertion et de probation sur trois
ans
nous aurons toujours besoin de ménager
notre parc pénitentiaire dans l'état
actuel est loin d'être
satisfaisant et où l'on cellulement
individuel qui devrait pourtant être la
règle depuis la loi pénitentiaire est
loin d'être la réalité et je crois qu'il
faut d'abord appliquer cette loi
pénitentiaire vous prévoyez d'ailleurs
madame la garde des sceaux un programme
d'extension et de rénovation important
du parc clignotantiaire permettant si je
me rappelle bien la création de 6000
nouvelles places pour la fermeture d'un
peu plus de 6500 pour la fermeture d'un
peu plus de 1000 places existantes et
personne ne peut dire que ce programme
n'est pas absolument nécessaire il est
même indispensable et il doit constituer
une priorité
mais face à cela il y a et là cela dure
réalité budgétaire qui montre qu'il est
quasiment impossible aujourd'hui de
poursuivre budgétairement plusieurs
lèvres à la fois notamment dans le
domaine de la justice ou les moyens
évoluent certes souvent plus vite que
dans la plupart des autres secteurs
d'intervention de l'État mais où nous
avons encore un tel retard à combler par
rapport à la plupart des pays
comparables or c'est vrai au terme de
l'examen de ce texte par les deux
assemblées de l'accord majoritaire qui a
été trouvé en commission mixte paritaire
la loi évite un certain nombre d'excès
que nous pouvions craindre avant que le
débat ait lieu et qui aurait pu
s'apparenter à un détricotage en règle
de toutes les mesures prises en matière
pénale avant 2012 je pense notamment à
la suppression de la rétention de sûreté
qui a été évitée et à une quasi
systématisation de l'application de
mettre un pénal pour tenter de remédier
à la surpopulation dans les prisons oui
c'est vrai nous avons évité que la
contrainte pénale devienne la peine
principale pour certains délits
contrairement à ce qu'avait initialement
proposé notre rapporteur s'agissant des
délits passifs de 50 emprisonnement au
risque de donner alors un message de
laxisme redoutable pour notre société
oui il faut sortir du tout carcéral qui
a souvent été dénoncé mais parfois avec
quand même beaucoup d'exagération car
combien de courte peine en réalité ne
sont pas exécutées mais lui aussi il
faut poursuivre l'effort de rénovation
et d'extension de notre parc
pénitentiaire comme prévu par la loi de
2009 et de toute évidence les moyens
vont manquer pour mener tout cela de
front j'espère me tromper
mais la décision prise lors de la CMP de
généraliser à partir de 2017
l'application de la contrainte pénale
comme peine alternative applicable à
tous les délits c'est à dire y compris
ceux qui sont passés de 10 ans
d'empriseonnement sans prendre le temps
de faire préalablement un bilan sur la
manière dont les deux premières années
de mise en œuvre de cette nouvelle peine
ce seront passées et sans ajuster le
nombre de créations de postes de
conseiller d'insertion et de probation
qui sont prévues dans le texte car on
prévoit 1000 postes mais ces mille
postes ont été calibrés pour une
nouvelle peine
applicable
pour les délits passibles de 5 ans et
non pas les délits passibles de 10 ans
et bien tout ça
va nous amener en l'état à voter contre
cette loi
ce qui ne m'empêche pas à titre
personnel je dois le dire d'espérer
qu'un jour notre justice est des moyens
suffisants pour que l'on puisse
réellement et en toute sécurité mieux
adaptée les peines à la personnalité des
délinquants mais aujourd'hui même si je
rends hommage votre volonté et votre
ténacité madame la garde des sceaux je
crains hélas que le compte n'y soit pas
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Eliane assassy
pour le groupe CRC
Michel le président madame la garde des
sceaux mes chers collègues donc ce
projet de loi dont on peut regretter
quand même la procédure accélérée et
toutefois
issu d'un long travail de concertation
il entend donc prévenir efficacement la
Russie div et donner du sens à la peine
loin des débats engendrés trop souvent
sous le coût de l'émotion auquel
l'apprécie la précédente majorité nous
avait habitué en matière pénale donc ce
texte se donne des objectifs
précis sortir du tout carcéral insister
sur la personnalisation des peines
supprimer les mécanismes automatiques
faisant échec à l'individualisation des
peines et donc construire un parcours
d'exécution de peine un parcours
efficace dans la prévention des risques
de récidive
je dois dire madame la garde des sceaux
que nous approuvons l'ensemble de ces
objectifs même si nous aurions voulu
aller plus loin et par exemple nous
regrettons que la commission mixte
paritaire soit revenue sur certaines
dispositions qui nous semblait
importantes la mesure phare de ce texte
qui défend l'idée que la peine ne doit
plus être synonyme de privation de
liberté c'est donc la contrainte pénale
il s'agit d'une peine
effectue en milieu ouvert entièrement
tourné vers le suivi socio-éducatif du
condamné elle est conçue donc comme un
mode de sanction moins sévère que la
peine d'emprisonnement comme on peut
l'entendre un peu trop souvent mais plus
efficace car plus adapté au traitement
de la plupart des délits et l'expérience
montre qu'une peine qui est exécutée en
milieu ouvert peut s'avérer plus
contraignante qu'une peine de prison car
elle comporte une obligation de
résultats la personne condamnée sera
absolument tenue de suivre les
injonctions qui lui seront fixées
infinés celles d'aller de l'avant en ce
sens en termes de lutte contre la
récidive la contrainte pénale sera de
notre point de vue plus efficace qu'une
peine passive effectuée en prison dans
les conditions que nous savons ce texte
porte aussi l'exigence d'une
individualisation de la peine selon la
personnalité vous l'avez évoqué du
condamné avec notamment la suppression
de mécanismes automatiques limitant les
possibilités d'individualisation vous
connaissez madame la garde et ceux la
position de notre groupe sur cette
question nous avons constamment et
depuis un certain nombre d'années
défendus cette exigence à travers des
propositions de loi que nous avons
déposé et chacun en mémoire ici les
prises de position particulière de mon
de mon ami Nicole Bordeaux Cohen seat à
ce sujet je soulignerai une innovation
quand même majeure de ce projet de loi
c'est la césure pénale ce dispositif
permettra de ménager opportunément le
temps de la réflexion en autorisant des
investigations qui aideront à décider de
la peine la plus adaptée à la
personnalité du condamné et donc de
mieux prévenir la récidive donc mon
groupe salut et soutien la très grande
majorité des mesures de ce texte mais il
y a bien un mais il nous semble que sur
certains points
nous aurions pu aller un peu plus loin
par exemple il a été finalement choisi
de maintenir la rétention de sûreté
pourtant notre commission l'avait
supprimé nous regrettons contre que
contre toute attente la majorité
actuelle qui l'attend dénoncé et
finalement décidé de la maintenir et de
la introduire en sciences publiques pour
préserver soi-disant un certain
équilibre du texte pour nous
ce projet était le véhicule
adapté pour la supprimer mais voilà
il y a nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
l'impasse dans la même manière nous
recrutons que la justice des mineurs
soit l'oublier d'un projet de loi
relative à l'individualisation des
peines l'instauration de tribunaux
correctionnel pour mineur c'était fait
son travail de concertation est
constitué à une profonde régression par
rapport aux principes fondateur de
l'ordonnance de 45 lequel fait primer
l'éducatif sur le répressif
cela dit madame a gardé son nous prenons
hâte de votre volonté de les supprimer
dans les prochains mois le groupe CRC
qui considère que la priorité éducative
n'exclut pas la fermeté et porteur d'un
certain nombre de propositions nous
sommes donc disponibles pour travailler
en concertation sur ce sujet afin de
redonner à l'ordonnance de 45 que des
lois successives ont étouffées donc de
redonner à cette ordonnance son ambition
initiale c'est-à-dire une juste
conciliation entre la protection de la
jeunesse et une répression de la
délinquance des mineurs mesurées et
adaptés donc malgré ces quelques reculs
nous approuvons bien entendu ce texte
qui pour nous est un texte progressiste
qui redonne au juge les outils pour
considérer les délinquants autrement
qu'à travers un acte ou une énumération
de fait et donc en soutenant son texte
nous ce texte nous réaffirmons ce que
nous avons soutenu lors de la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 c'est à savoir la
peine doit aussi être un temps pour se
reconstruire et se réinsérer c'est selon
nous le seul moyen efficace pour le
lutter contre la récidive que la peine
soit purgé en milieu ouvert ou en milieu
fermé la contrainte pénale bien que
limitée pour le moment dans son champ
d'application il contribuera très
certainement malgré ce qu'en disent tout
c'est des tracteurs donc nous voterons
en faveur de ce texte mais permettez-moi
de dire ici qu'en soutenant ce texte je
veux aussi et je sors un petit peu du
sujet qui nous occupe ce matin mais je
dois vous dire que je suis très en
colère donc je voudrais envoyer ici si
vous le permettez à garder sauts et
monsieur le Président un message au
ministre soi-disant chargé des relations
avec le Parlement
pour lui dire avec fermeté de ravaler
son anticommunisme et d'entendre pour le
moins primaire et d'entendre ceci
quand un projet de loi qui nous occupe
comme celui de ce matin est un bon texte
qui porte des valeurs de gauche nous le
votons
quand cela n'est pas les cas le cas nous
ne les votons pas ce qui ne devrait être
une surprise pour personne tant nous
l'avons dit redit écrit réécris alors je
voudrais dire à ce ministre que quand il
était député il a voté avec l'UMP le
traité Merkel Sarkozy
qui plombe un peu quand même notre pays
aujourd'hui dans la crise que
qui renforce la crise que connaît notre
pays et donc je le prierai de ravaler
effectivement son anti-communisme
légendaire après pas que primaire
légendaire pour se consacrer un peu
mieux à la mission qui lui a été confiée
par le Premier ministre et surtout
surtout que ce ministre déploie son
énergie son énergie à mettre des
contenus à l'idée d'une politique de
gauche mais je ne suis pas sûr que cela
est encore du sens pour lui et je
regrette enfin que le président du
groupe socialiste ici au Sénat
s'inscrivent dans les bas dans les pas
de Monsieur Le Guen voilà je vous
remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Virginie classe
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
n'ayant pas ce qui me concerne les mêmes
motifs de colère que ma collègue
néanmoins je partage
ce qu'elle a exprimé sur le regret de la
procédure accélérée nous avons été déjà
nombreux à le dire à cette tribune et je
ne renierai pas ce que j'ai moi-même
déjà dit de nombreuses fois à cette
tribune il est vrai que la navette
parlementaire permet souvent d'améliorer
les textes néanmoins néanmoins ce n'est
pas non plus l'alpha et l'oméga ni une
garantie à 100%, ne serait-ce que les
textes de loi wasman que l'on voit
régulièrement passer sont là pour
rectifier un certain nombre d'erreurs
d'inexactitudes ou d'inadaptation d'un
certain nombre de textes de loi votés
sans la procédure accélérée et puis en
ce qui concerne le texte qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui cela a déjà été dit et redit
également il a fait l'objet d'une très
large concertation en amont de sa
présentation et même de son écriture il
a fait l'objet de très nombreux débats
et auditions dans les deux chambres du
Parlement la CMP elle-même sous l'égide
des rapporteurs et des présidents des
commissions à énormément travaillé
jusque dans la rédaction d'un certain
nombre où la roue rédaction d'un certain
nombre d'articles et enfin et enfin ce
qu'il me semble particulièrement
important l'évaluation de cette loi de
ces résultats et déjà prévu la mesure de
son efficacité et déjà prévue et les
rectifications éventuelles nécessaires
ou utiles sont déjà prévus donc au vu de
l'ensemble de ces éléments ne valait-il
pas effectivement mieux gagner quelques
mois et voter cette loi plus rapidement
de façon à ce qu'elle soit appliquée et
qu'elle puisse être évaluée plus
rapidement aussi sur le fond sur le fond
je n'ai pas et pourtant je suis assez
souvent présente au Sénat mais j'ai pas
rencontré beaucoup de dangereux laxistes
qui n'ont qu'une envie c'est qu'on
agresse leurs parents ou leurs enfants
et que ce soit fait en toute impunité à
part le rapporteur Jean-Pierre Michel
puisqu'il s'est déjà assis décrit sans
doute moi-même puisque je partage en
l'occurrence les options et Madame
assassy également bien donc nous sommes
déjà trois dangereux et laxistes qui ne
rêvons que que d'impunité pour la
délinquance mais à part nous trois donc
j'en ai pas rencontré d'autres donc
globalement les objectifs sont partagés
effectivement de punir les délinquants
de punir la délinquance et de limiter la
récidive après la question c'est est-ce
qu'il fallait rester sur les options
précédentes et construire des prisons où
est-ce qu'il fallait changer
complètement de regard alors construire
des prisons madame la ministre vous avez
déjà eu l'occasion de le rappeler
plusieurs fois non seulement le premier
euro d'investissement n'était pas prévu
mais qui plus est quand on nous parle
aujourd'hui des moyens à mettre en
oeuvre en termes de personnel sur ce
texte de loi je rappelle aussi que les
moyens en personnel à mettre en oeuvre
pour les éventuels place de prison dont
il était éventuellement prévu qu'elle
serait construite un jour avec de
l'argent qui n'existait pas encore tous
ces personnels là n'étaient pas non plus
prévues ni en recrutement ni en budget
donc il y avait là aussi de sérieusement
que sur le sujet alors le la position
qui était prise par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui a été de dire et bien non on
va changer le regard ce que j'ai vu et
ce que j'ai entendu sur le sujet était
oui mais la prison est une sanction plus
dure donc plus efficace
c'est un paradigme contre lequel auquel
je me pose fermement plus dur ça veut
dire quoi dur et parfaitement subjectif
et c'est le ressenti de la personne à
qui s'applique la peine qui est à
prendre en considération une peine de
prison plus dure
est-elle quelque chose de totalement
subjectif ensuite est-ce que parce
qu'une peine est dure elle est efficace
et que doit viser le législateur une
peine dure donc une espèce de d'esprit
de revanche de vengeance ou une peine
efficace c'est-à-dire la mise à l'abri
de la société le rétablissement du droit
du droit si nécessaire et de l'ordre
public
personnellement je suivrai beaucoup plus
le gouvernement sur cette deuxième
option qui est la sanction doit être
efficace et la dureté d'une sanction n'a
aucune signification en tant que telle
une sanction doit être adaptée à la
personnalité de la personne qui a fait
l'acte délictueux elle doit être adaptée
à l'acte lui-même aux circonstances de
l'acte elle n'a pas à être dure elle
doit être juste et efficace
c'est donc ce que nous propose la
contrainte pénale mesure farm de votre
texte de loi et je
reprendrai l'exemple qui a été cité par
le président Yeste enfin juriste et
finaliste même si là non plus je ne
partage pas forcément c'est conclusions
pas plus qu'il ne partage celle de
Jean-Pierre Michel qui nous a parlé d'un
cambriolage et en disant c'est vrai que
la personne qui est cambriolée est
atteinte dans son intimité il a
entièrement raison mais quand il parle
de cet exemple là je me rappelle moi de
cette personne qui œuvrait pour la
réparation pénale vis-à-vis de mineur et
qui à titre d'exemple particulièrement
réussi de réparation pénale qui
ressemble malgré tout étrangement à la
contrainte pénale mais la réparation
pénale est adaptée aux mineurs et qui me
disait qu'il avait suivi une bande de
gamins mineurs qui avait de 13 à 16 ans
et qu'il était s'amusait s'amusait à
effectivement rentrer dans des villas
les dévastées piquets tout ce qui
pouvait trouver appliqué casser vous
pouvez trouver à casser et trouver ça
très drôle ces enfants là ils ont pas
été mis en prison ils ont pas été mis en
centre éducatif fermé ils ont été pris
en charge dans une mesure de réparation
pénale ils ont pris conscience de leur
acte et cette personne qui les suivait
m'a dit on en a plus jamais revu aucun
devant aucun tribunal donc oui une
sanction à partir du moment où elle est
juste ou elle est comprise où elle est
suivie ou les adapter à la personnalité
une fois de plus de du délinquant
peut-être mille fois plus efficace
qu'une peine d'emprisonnement comme on
en connaît aujourd'hui
alors Monsieur yes nous disait aussi que
la contrainte pénale était une peine
alternative non justement la contrainte
pénale est un changement de regard un
changement de position par rapport à la
délinquance et par rapport au délinquant
et justement la contrainte pénale se
doit de vivre en dehors de la prison qui
ne doit plus être la seule référence de
peine sinon on tourne en rond autour de
la sanction dure ou la sanction efficace
donc au final le texte qui est sorti de
cette CMP me semble être un texte nous
semble au groupe PS un texte équilibré
un texte équilibré un texte novateur
avec là encore un nouveau regard porté
sur l'acte de délinquance mais pas
seulement sur l'acte de délinquance on
oublie trop souvent que l'acte de
délinquance est commis par un délinquant
et par une personne donc c'est aussi un
nouveau regard sur les délinquants et
sur le contexte familial social le
contexte de vie de ces délinquants le
contexte dans lequel ils ont commis les
actes de délinquance avec l'idée de
l'inclusion et non pas de l'exclusion la
fermeté de la réponse pénale est
affirmée par le biais de la contrainte
pénale et clairement affirmée ainsi que
l'individualisation de cette peine qui
est confortée la prison redevient un
dernier recours ce qu'elle n'aurait
jamais dû cesser d'être et les sorties
en seront accompagnées parce que c'est
indispensable si on veut lutter contre
la récidive plus de Monsieur B je vais
pas revenir sur le cas de ce de cette
personne mais plus de Monsieur B en
France demain ça ce serait un vrai rêve
et ça ce serait une vraie réussite
la société est protégée l'ordre public
est conforté
comme d'autres jours aussi ce regret de
du tribunal correctionnel pour mineur
qui n'a pas été aboli par le biais de ce
texte de loi mais comme d'autres aussi
madame la ministre j'ai bien entendu les
promesses du gouvernement sur le sujet
et ici ou ailleurs je continuerai de
suivre ce sujet et de suivre
l'engagement du gouvernement alors on
aurait pu c'est vrai aller plus vite
aller plus loin c'est la preuve que
beaucoup de choses avec la conférence de
consensus ont été remués que beaucoup
d'idées en ont jailli que beaucoup de
personnes se sont emparées du sujet mais
le pas de changement de regard est fait
le pas est franchi il est prudent mais
il est sûr en rendant un dernier hommage
un autre rapporteur Jean-Pierre Michel
pour le travail apporter la cohérence et
sa ténacité le même hommage à Madame la
Ministre pour son opiniâtreté et sa
ténacité également le groupe suivra bien
évidemment le texte et le votera dès
demain
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur Jean-René
Lecerf pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
je ne m'exprime pas au nom du groupe UMP
mais en mon nom personnel
et je souhaiterais d'abord remercier mon
groupe de m'avoir accordé tant en
première et unique lecture
qu'aujourd'hui un temps de parole
signification alors que nul ni ignorait
nos divergences d'opinion sur ce projet
de loi
tout à fait
vous le savez je suis très attaché à la
loi pénitentiaire de 2009 non pas parce
que j'en ai été le rapporteur mais parce
que j'ai conscience qu'elle a marqué une
rupture profonde et nécessaire avec
l'humiliation pour la République qui
caractérisait jusque-là notre universel
or ce projet de loi sur
l'individualisation des peines et le
renforcement de l'efficacité des
sanctions pénales s'ados c'est
d'indiscutable et c'est heureux sur la
loi pénitentiaire qu'il s'agisse du sens
de la peine de la volonté de faire de la
prison en matière délictuelles
l'exception l'ultime recours
ou de l'abandon des querelles stériles
entre la primauté de la lutte contre la
récidive ou celle de la réinsertion
alors que celle-ci constitue le meilleur
moyen de lutter contre celle là
je suis convaincu que nous cherchons
tous sur tous ces bancs la réponse la
plus efficace la délinquance et que nous
savons tous qu'elle ne peut résider
exclusivement dans la multiplication des
places de prison
je suis également convaincu qu'il n'y a
pas de bonne justice sans la confiance
de nos concitoyens et qu'il importe de
retisser la confiance des Français dans
leur justice on pourrait d'ailleurs dire
la même chose mais chers collègues de la
politique et des politiques le fossé ne
date pas d'hier et des illusions de
l'actualité voilà quelques années un
sondage réalisé à l'initiative du
Conseil de la magistrature cloué au
pylori de la défiance journaliste
politique et magistrats le travail de la
commission mixte paritaire ces déforcé
de concilier des points de vue parfois
largement divergents de nos deux
assemblées rendant ainsi à notre
bicamérisme des lettres de noblesse qui
menaçaient de ce ternir
il a aussi contribué
à ajouter il a aussi contribué par
donnez-moi à rejeter les réformes dans
les réformes dans la réforme nous avions
déjà écarté les dispositions relatives à
la rétention de sûreté j'avais fait
observer qu'il était bien malaisé de
tenter une évaluation d'une loi pour
l'essentiel inappliquer en raison de sa
non rétroactivité la commission mixte
paritaire a fait de même en ce qui
concerne les tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs certes le Parlement aura à
connaître au début de l'an prochain
d'une réforme de l'ordonnance de 45 mais
à tout le moins pourra-t-on aborder le
problème de l'enfance délinquante dans
sa globalité et non au hasard d'un
amendement ponctuel
sur l'une des novations essentielles de
la réforme la contrainte pénale il a été
renoncé à en faire une peine autonome
ont couru à titre de peine principale
pour une série de délits elle redevient
ainsi du moins pour le moment une simple
alternative à l'emprisonnement
doté cependant de moyens de contrôle
renforcés Portalis
oserais-je dire que je parle ici sous
son contrôle devrait s'en satisfaire lui
qui déclarait il faut être
sobre de nouveautés en matière de
législation parce que s'il est possible
de calculer les avantages que la théorie
nous offre il ne l'est pas de connaître
tous les inconvénients que la pratique
seul peut découvrir fin de citation
sur les seuils d'aménagement de peine
j'avoue ma satisfaction de voir
conserver la solution de la loi
pénitentiaire aménagement possible pour
les peines de deux ans au plus pour les
primo condamnés et d'un an plus pour les
récidivistes ces dispositions auront
finalement résisté à bien des récidives
gouvernementales
satisfaction encore devoir reconnu
l'atténuation de responsabilité pénale
pour les personnes condamnées souffrant
d'une altération de leur discernement
évolution d'autant plus indispensable
que la distinction altération abolition
largement brouillée par le déficit de
lipsychiatrique en milieu fermé nous
convainc de plus en plus difficilement
aujourd'hui
c'est un vote unanime du Sénat datant de
près de trois ans et demi qui se trouve
qui trouve ainsi sa consécration
on ne peut t'éluder l'éternel débat sur
un recul de l'emprisonnement qui
marquerait un désarmement de la
protection de la société propice au
développement de la délinquance et de la
récidive
questionnement que l'on retrouve pour la
contrainte penal comme ce fut le cas en
matière d'aménagement de peine ou
d'alternative à l'incarcération mais la
réponse n'est-elle pas directement liée
au moyen dont on disposera
pour mettre en oeuvre et contrôler
obligation et interdiction imposée aux
personnes condamnées développées le
nombre et le contenu des tiges les
travaux d'intérêt général et renforcer
considérablement l'indispensable
accompagnement humain conditions
essentielles de la qualité de la
réinsertion et partant de l'absence de
récidive comme le noter en CMP notre
collègue Yves de traigne n'est-il pas
prématuré de prévoir dès maintenant la
généralisation de la contrainte pénale à
tous les délits à compter du 1er janvier
2017 alors que les moyens de suivre
l'exécution des contraintes pénales sont
limitées et ne devrait probablement pas
augmenter massivement d'ici là
même si j'en comprends les raisons je
regrette à cet égard la suppression par
la CMP de la possibilité qui avait été
votée par le Sénat de déléguer à des
associations la mise en oeuvre de
certaines peines elle aurait apporté une
part de souplesse qui ne pourra être
compensée que par des recrutements
massives de personnels d'insertion et de
probation l'exemple de la loi
pénitentiaire s'avère peu encourageant
sur ce point et je doute à la fois du
respect des promesses et même si par
bonheur elles étaient tenues qu'elle
suffisent à faire face à la montée des
besoins que la réforme devrait générer
or pour que cette réforme marque un
progrès il faut que chacun de nos
concitoyens comprennent bien que la
contrainte pénale comme les aménagements
de peine ne sont pas des cadeaux
féodelinquants des procédures dont ils
peuvent bénéficier ce verbe n'est pas
innocent mais qu'il s'agit tout au
contraire d'autres modalités de purger
sa peine qui seront considérés par
certains comme plus difficile que l'on
fermement mais qui sont davantage
porteurs d'avenir que l'emprisonnement
notamment dans les conditions où il est
aujourd'hui encore mis en oeuvre avec
une offre de travail qui n'a jamais été
aussi limitée en dépit de l'obligation
d'activité voulue par le législateur un
taux de détention qui atteint le ratio
de 105 pour 100000 habitants une
augmentation sensible du nombre de
détenus dormants sur un matelas posé à
même le sol des conditions de détention
détestable dans bien des maisons d'arrêt
mes chers collègues
je ne me berce pas d'illusions sur la
capacité de ce texte à modifier
radicalement la situation de l'univers
carcéral et de lutte contre la récidive
ou sur ses chances d'impliquer la
société tout entière bien au-delà des
juges des forces de l'ordre et de
l'administration pénitentiaire dans
l'accompagnement de cette réforme mais
je crois que la contrainte pénale comme
le refus des sorties sèches apportent
une pierre supplémentaire à l'édifice de
la loi pénitentiaire
je crains en outre qu'au fil des
alternances qui s'enchaînent
régulièrement depuis plus de 30 ans dans
notre pays les nouvelles majorités ne
s'évertu perpétuellement à défaire le
travail de celles qui les ont précédés
dans des domaines qui requièrent
pourtant continuité et sérénités ce
projet de loi c'est en tout cas ma
conviction respecte laquis de la loi
pénitentielle et on développe même un
certain nombre de virtualité c'est la
raison pour laquelle je lui apporterai
mon suffrage comme j'aurais en son temps
souhaité que la loi pénitentiaire
recueille davantage d'un sentiment dans
cette assemblée sur les rangs de
l'opposition de l'époque je vous
remercie
la discussion générale est close
ou après peut-être non comme vous
souhaitez madame la ministre cependant
vous aurez le temps aussi en présentant
comme vous le souhaitez
bien je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement le
Sénat examinant après l'Assemblée
nationale le texte élaboré par la
commission mix paritaire il se prononce
par un seul vote sur l'ensemble du texte
en ne retenant que les amendements
présentés et acceptés par le
gouvernement et nous allons donc passer
à la présentation des amendements du
Gouvernement
vous pourrez en même temps vous exprimer
si vous le souhaitez madame la ministre
bien entendu
je vous en prie
oui
monsieur le Président j'avoue que sur le
règlement du Sénat je suis toujours un
peu plus prudente et circonspecte
parce que je connais mieux celui de
l'Assemblée je n'ai aucun mérite c'est
juste de l'avoir pratiqué donc voilà
j'aimerais réflexe merci oui je
souhaitais d'abord par correction et par
respect vis-à-vis des parlementaires des
sénatrices et sénateurs qui se sont
exprimés remercier toutes les oratrices
et tous les orateurs pour la qualité de
leurs interventions pour la façon dont
ils ont appuyé le contenu des
dispositions le contenu de ce texte et
les dispositions dont il perçoit bien à
la fois la pertinence et l'efficacité
attendue les remercier de contribuer à
la compréhension à les télégibilité
l'intelligibilité de ce texte parce que
cela peut s'avérer nécessaire les
magistrats qui voudront s'approprier ce
texte pourront parfois s'interroger sur
l'intention du législateur et la qualité
des interventions permettra de de savoir
ce que souhaitait le législateur y
compris d'ailleurs lorsque les
interventions sont de contestations
d'interrogations de mise en cause
puisque elles permettent des réponses et
de permettre donc d'Ét couper le débat
parlementaire et donc de bien asseoir ce
que souhaite le législateur dans une
démocratie c'est bien le législateur qui
élabore les règles communes c'est bien
lui qui a la responsabilité de dire sur
quelles règles nous vivons et il est bon
que ceux qui doivent appliquer au
quotidien ces règles comprennent bien la
tension de ce législateur je voudrais
revenir sur donc merci à chacune chacun
pour ces interventions notamment ceux
qui ont soutenu ce texte et qui surtout
l'enrichit pendant ces travaux j'entends
évidemment les regrets sur la procédure
accélérée je reviens pas sur ce que j'ai
dit
lors de la première et unique lecture
comme on dit encore que là je pense
qu'il y a une lecture de qualité
voilà la loi pénitentiaire avait fait
l'objet
d'une procédure accélérée elle n'a pas
perdu en qualité et n'a pas perdu en
qualité et pourtant elle n'avait pas
fait l'objet d'une maturation aussi
longue que ce texte de loi dont je
rappelle que vous avez suivi de très
près
tout le processus d'élaboration
tout en sachant à quel point nous avions
déjà du matériau de qualité ce qui
n'intera rien bien entendu le travail
qui a été produit par les membres du du
jury de consensus
sur quelques observations d'une façon
générale je suis toujours à ses étonnée
lorsque j'entends vous envoyer un
message au délinquant moi je n'ai pas le
sentiment je n'ai pas la voir d'être en
dialogue avec les délinquants la
responsabilité législative celle que
vous assumez et celle que le
gouvernement introduit c'est une
responsabilité qui consiste à élaborer
des règles et à s'interroger pour la
qualité la pertinence et la durabilité
pardon pour le caractère peu élégant du
terme de ces règles sur l'histoire de ce
pays sur les valeurs de ce pays sur la
culture de ce pays et c'est ça
le dialogue nous l'avons avec nous-mêmes
nous l'avons avec la société pas avec
l'un délinquant et moi je ne dirais pas
que sur les dix années des deux
précédents quinquennat où il y a eu je
le rappelle une centaine de
modifications du droit pénal et de la
procédure pénale je ne dirai pas que
vous étiez en dialogue non plus avec un
délinquance sinon je dirais à ce
moment-là mauvaise foi contre mauvaise
foi que cette instabilité que cet
inconstance
cette imprévisibilité on peut être
perçue par l'un délinquant comme des
marques de faiblesse et donc allons-y
mais ça n'a pas de sens parce que les
délinquants eux-mêmes ne s'interrogent
pas quant à savoir quelle est
l'intention du législateur quelle
nouvelle règle il a mise quel va être la
sanction de telle hâte malheureusement
ça ne peut se passe pas comme ça si le
dialogue avait lieu ben ce serait
beaucoup plus simple de combattre les
délinquance donc voilà moi je n'arrive
jamais à comprendre alors lorsque c'est
totalement
polémique bon voilà on laisse passer
lorsque ça semble de devenir un argument
voilà je pense que ça mérite une réponse
parce que un argument ça se respecte et
donc ça on y répond donc voilà moi je
pense que la question n'est vraiment pas
là la question est de savoir si ce qui a
été fait c'est pour ça que nous avons
choisi cette méthode c'est pour ça que
nous avons choisi de mettre en place
cette conférence de consensus c'est pour
ça que moi j'ai fait un tour de France
sur ce texte de loi que je suis allée
l'expliquer y compris à des publics très
hostiles j'ai eu des expériences ou les
20 premières minutes étaient très très
dur avec des personnes totalement
endoctrinées conditionné endocriné parce
que l'échange ne portait pas sur le
contenu du texte il portait sur des
choses qui n'avaient strictement rien à
voir du texte mais qui était un espèce
de propagande qui prospirait depuis plus
d'un an donc voilà j'ai reçu j'ai
organisé j'ai proposé des rencontres
avec des élus locaux qui des rencontres
qui se sont tenues à la Chancellerie je
me suis déplacée dans des mairies dans
des conseils généraux dans des conseils
régionaux je suis allé des Français les
rencontrer et leur parler de ce texte du
contenu de ce texte de notre droit pénal
et je lorsque je parle de notre droit
pénal ça n'est pas pour le vilipandé ça
n'est pas pour le discréditer parce que
si nous nous respectons pas ce qui fait
le fondement de de notre vie commune
personne ne peut ne peut le respecter
donc voilà je dis nous avons été
disposition elle s'avère inefficace il
nous faut travailler pour voir comment
on les rend efficaces alors vous dites
monsieur le Président Yester a dit en
tout cas la tribune que nous changeons
de philosophie c'est pour ça qu'il ne
votent pas ce texte merci monsieur le
sénateur le cerf d'avoir dit qu'au
contraire nous nous inscrivons dans la
philosophie de la loi pénitentiaire nous
nous inscrivons dans la philosophie de
la loi pénitentiaire et nous nous
inscrivons surtout dans la philosophie
dans l'histoire
du projet pénal républicain français
nous nous inscrivons dans cela et les 10
années de bouleversement du droit pénal
et de la procédure pénale ont été une
parenthèse c'est ça la parenthèse
je l'ai rappelé lorsque lors de mon
intervention en première lecture
l'histoire est en particulier la place
qu'a occupé le Sénat dans le projet
pénal républicain les sénateurs
républicains les sénateurs de droite et
sénateurs du centre évidemment aussi les
sénateurs de gauche évidemment les
députés de gauche mais aussi des gardes
des sceaux de droite républicains qui
ont participé qui ont construit qui ont
consolidé le projet pénal républicain
qui ont considéré ce que nous sommes en
train de faire là en rétablissant en
reconstruisant une pénalité moderne
républicaine considéré que l'acte de
délinquance mérite sanction mais que la
sanction doit faire sens pour la société
elle doit faire sens pour la victime
elle doit faire sens pour l'auteur et
qu'il n'y a pas d'incompatibilité entre
la sanction et le travail de réinsertion
mais c'est ça le projet pénal
républicain et c'est ça l'histoire
de la France l'histoire du droit pénal
français et les dix années où il y a eu
à la fois une
aggravation des réponses répressives un
allongement de la durée d'incarcération
mais aussi des injonctions
contradictoires c'est-à-dire réprimer de
plus en plus enfermé de plus en plus
longtemps mais aménager de plus en plus
de plus en plus vite voilà c'est c'était
ça la parenthèse donc nous sortons de là
et je vois pas l'utilité à caractériser
cela je dis simplement voilà nous avons
eu le souci pendant deux ans d'analyser
d'examiner d'évaluer d'interroger par
point par point par exemple c'est
Philippe là c'est Philippe et l'absap
qui ont été des mécanismes de la même sa
façon qu'on a moins il y avait des
mécanismes pour augmenter
l'incarcération il y avait en aval des
mécanismes pour essayer de dégager de
gérer les flux carcéraux c'était la
surveillance électronique de fin de
peine
et la la procédure simplifiée
d'aménagement de peine parce que de
toute façon le système était embolisé il
fallait le régler donc voilà mais je
veux dire que je ne porte même pas de
jugement de valeur là dessus
donc nous essayons de rectifier ça nous
avons supprimé ces automatismes ce Damon
et ceux d'aval et puis nous mettons en
place un dispositif qui doit être
efficace vous avez le souci des moyens
et c'est légitime c'est légitime mais le
gouvernement il y a répondu alors je
veux bien que vous entendiez la réponse
les réponses et que vous disiez
néanmoins on pense que vous n'arriverez
pas à le faire néanmoins même si c'est
déjà acté même si c'est déjà en cours
parce que les 400 recrutements pour les
services pénitentiaires d'insertion de
probation déjà eu lieu pour l'année 2014
il n'y a pas de raison de douter de des
300 de 2015 de 2014 sont en place donc
moi j'entends bien machin mais j'ai
envie de vous dire mais lutter lutter
lutter résolument contre cette
pessimisme qui veut vous envahir vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'être pessimiste
parce que je le répète et je le pense
très sincèrement vous avez beaucoup de
mérites moi je crois qu'on va y arriver
nous avons mis les conditions pour y
arriver les conditions normatives mais
position politique publique et vous avez
du mérite parce que lorsque je dis que
vous avez produit pendant de nombreuses
années du matériau que le Sénat pendant
des années enfin je vous ai rappelé
Bérenger et tous ces personnages c'est
c'est la fin du 19e siècle et même
depuis le début sous la Restauration
l'Ancien Régime il y a des réflexions
sur les régimes pénitentiaires donc
voilà donc on n'est pas en train de tout
inventer et on va pas accaparer tous les
mérites il y a la possibilité dans une
société de convenir à certains moments
que elle se retrouvait même sur ses
fondamentaux et que sur la base de ces
fondamentaux elle réussit des politiques
publiques donc voilà le gouvernement
vous a fait savoir nous renforçant le
service pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation nous l'augmentons de 25% en 3
ans nous avons commencé à recruter pour
l'aménage l'application des peines et
l'exécution des peines mais aussi des
greffiers depuis 2013 et nous continuons
vous savez que nous avons y faire
réformer le ndrp c'est à dire que nous
voulons des statistiques incontestables
parce que nous voulons mesurer vraiment
et nous voulons tellement mesurer que
nous avons proposé dans la loi ce que
vous avez maintenu une obligation de la
part du gouvernement d'évaluation et de
présentation par Le Mans de cette
évaluation au terme de deux ans c'est
quand même relevé nous fixer à nous-même
un défi terrible et nous le relevons
nous-mêmes donc nous avons réformé
l'office de l'observation de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales nous
avons créé un observatoire de la
récidive et la désistance nous lui
faisons échapper à l'emprise du
ministère donc nous voulons être en
capacité de mesurer les phénomènes de
délinquance mais aussi en capacité
d'analyser les facteurs qui favorisent
la résistance c'est à dire la sortie et
de la délinquance et nous le faisons de
façon complètement objective avec la
bonne distance nous avons développé
depuis 18 mois un travail int
mystérielle avec des conventions entre
le ministère de la Justice au ministère
de la Santé le ministère de la Justice
et le ministère de l'Éducation nationale
vous savez que nous avons une population
carcérale qui présente une sociologie
particulière puisque nous avons un taux
d'illettrisme qui est plus de trois fois
supérieur au taux national donc nous
avons une convention avec l'Éducation
nationale nous avons une convention avec
le ministère de l'Emploi du travail des
expérimentations avec des départements
et avec des conseils régionaux sur
l'insertion par l'économie sur un
certain nombre de processus de processus
donc ce travail est engagé ce travail
est engagé donc allons-y tous ensemble
et puis vous nous ferez griève si on
échoue vous nous tiendrez grief si des
engagements qui ont été pris n'ont pas
été suivis mais nous récolterons tous
ensemble de faire reculer la récidive de
faire reculer reculer l'un délinquance
d'améliorer la réinsertion de donner à
des personnes à nouveau l'accès à la
dignité d'elle-même et surtout à au
respect des règles de la société et donc
mettre à chacun d'avoir une vie de
plénitude pardon d'avoir été longue je
j'ai bien conscient de mettre un peu de
passion dans cette affaire mais cette
passion je sais que vous la partagez
vous la partagez parce que d'abord je
vous fréquente assez assidûment depuis
deux ans mais en plus je lis vos travaux
depuis plusieurs années donc voilà
pardon monsieur le Président pardon
mesdames sénatrices monsieur sénateurs
pour ce
long développement je vous présente donc
l'amendement je l'ai dit et le président
yes y a été sensible je crois le
gouvernement avait présenté plusieurs
amendements à présenter hier soir à
l'Assemblée nationale à plusieurs
amendements on alertant les députés sur
des risques constitutionnels
je le répète les risques
constitutionnels on les évalue ils sont
pas forcément objectivement réels en
tout cas ils vont pas forcément donner
lieu à une décision de censure du
Constitutionnel ils peuvent donner lieu
à une réserve d'interprétation ils
peuvent donner lieu aussi à bon voilà le
conseil peut considérer qu'il laisse
passer mais il est de notre devoir de
vous dire que nous avons juridiquement
détecter quelques risques
constitutionnels manifestement le
président Yeste partage cette analyse
puisque il a évoqué exactement les
sujets qui ont fait l'objet des
amendements présentés par le
gouvernement hier à l'Assemblée
nationale ils ont été rejetés donc nous
ne pouvons pas vous les représenter
l'amendement que je vous présente à
l'instant et donc l'amendement numéro 1
qui porte sur l'article 7.1 et qui
consiste à
rétablir un bout de phrase qui avait été
écrit ici au Sénat mais qui a été
supprimé par la commission mixte
paritaire c'est une disposition qui vise
à inciter les détenus à
l'apprentissage de la lecture du calcul
je parlais du taux d'illettrisme très
très élevé je dois rappeler d'ailleurs
que c'est une initiative qui venait d'un
député de l'UMP monsieur Jean-Frédéric
Poisson qui avait présenté un amendement
elle a maintenant nous a paru ne pas
pouvoir être adopté en l'état mais je
m'étais engagé moi à le faire travailler
ce que nous avons fait nous avons
proposé la disposition ici au Sénat donc
vous avez accepté de prendre de faire
prendre en considération les efforts
pour l'apprentissage de la lecture du
calcul et nous avions ajouté également
l'encouragement à participer à des
activités culturelles et notamment de
lecture
le la CMP la avait supprimé cette
branche de phrase probablement
considérant qu'il y avait une tautologie
il n'y a pas tautologie parce que cela
élargit le public qui va être concerné
c'est à dire que il y en a qui ne sont
pas illettrés mais qui n'ont pas la
pratique de la lecture et la
participation à des activités
culturelles ins ites dans dans leur
habitudes donc il y a une incitation à
un public plus large que celui qui est
strictement illettré et qu'on encourage
par le premier bout de phrase donc je
vous demande d'adopter cet amendement
de la commission donc avis de la
commission merci monsieur le président
le rapporteur puisque la commission de
séparé unie vous demande mes chers
collègues d'adopter ensemble ces quatre
amendements qui ont été adoptés par
l'Assemblée nationale Liège trois
amendements sont des amendements de
coordination et d'application de la loi
il ne posent pas de gros problèmes le
seul amendement de fond et l'amendement
cette terre a le premier qui revient
d'ailleurs au texte du Sénat à
réintroduisant la lecture donc nous ne
pouvons qu'être favorables effectivement
je lui demande donc d'accepter dans un
même vote les quatre rendements que
Madame les garde des sceaux vient de
vous présenter
madame la ministre souhaitez-vous
quelque chose sur les autres amendements
puisque vous n'en aviez présenté qu'un
je me sentais un peu censurée mais c'est
vrai merci
merci merci monsieur le sénateur donc
j'ai le droit de présenter les trois
voilà si vous le souhaitez merci
monsieur le Président donc le rapporteur
vient de vous proposer de voter des
trois autres amendements du Gouvernement
il y a un amendement qui consiste à
définir des dates de d'entrée en
application de certaines dispositions du
texte de loi parce que nous avons besoin
de mettre en place quelques dispositions
pratiques par exemple pour le casier
judiciaire l'adaptation du logiciel
informatique donc voilà les services ont
besoin de ce délai et nous vous
proposons donc de différer l'application
de certaines de ces dispositions une
partie en octobre 2014 une autre partie
en janvier 2015
et puis des deux derniers amendements
concernent ce sont des amendements de
coordination avec
soit le code de la famille le code de
l'action sociale et de la famille soit
avec la loi pénitentiaire en application
en
ynésie en Nouvelle-Calédonie à
Wallis-et-Futuna
bien donc conformément à l'article 42
alinéa 12 du règlement je vais mettre au
voile l'ensemble du projet de loi dans
la rédaction résultant du texte élaboré
par la commission mixte paritaire
modifiée par les amendements du
Gouvernement y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote monsieur Richards
oui monsieur le Président nous votons
bien sur l'ensemble du texte y incluant
ces quatre amendements sur lesquels on
aura donc pas de vote séparé d'accord il
y a un vote unique donc je vais faire
une explication de texture ce texte
comme Jean-Jacques vous l'a dit au titre
du groupe moi je vais aussi voter contre
pour les motifs qui ont été indiqués par
Monsieur monsieur Yeste mais pour être
tout à fait clair dans mon propos et
sans vouloir paraphraser notre collègue
Jacques mesard dans son exercice
d'explication de texte tout à l'heure
pour ma part je ne veux pas l'impunité
pour les délinquants quel qu'il soit
voilà c'est encore mieux dit comme ça
et j'ai moi aussi le sentiment qu'avec
ce nouveau texte nous prenons qu'on le
veuille ou non le risque d'un signal au
délinquant d'un allez je pèse mes mots
d'un certain laxisme à cet égard pour
autant comme d'autres et on l'a dit
toute la matinée et
en lecture précédente je souhaite que
nous en finitions avec la récidive avec
on l'a encore dit ce matin avec les
sorties sèches comme on dit sur ce point
à l'issue des travaux de la CMP a-t-on
quelques garanties que le texte qui nous
est transmis va véritablement améliorer
les perspectives
notamment parce ce qui est introduite la
contrainte pénale qui est un reste un
concept flou dont on ne sait pas
exactement aujourd'hui ce qu'il est si
ce n'est peut-être un
super sur scie avec mise à l'épreuve
mais qui pourtant en s'appliquant à tous
les délits punissables de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement à leur actuelle en 2017
pourrait devenir un outil tout à fait
redoutable de du droit pénal nous
l'avons dit il y avait déjà il y a
encore un beau texte pour améliorer la
situation à cet égard c'est la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 si celle-ci n'a
pas eu les résultats escompté c'est
naturellement dû au manque de moyens
mis en oeuvre pour son application alors
arrivera-t-on à dégager plus de moyens
aujourd'hui pour l'application de cette
nouvelle loi qui précisément va en
exigeait plus
pourquoi d'ailleurs ne pas avoir
appliqué plus de moyens déjà depuis deux
ans puisque nous ne l'avons pas fait
moi je suis pas persuadé que parce que
cette nouvelle loi va exiger encore plus
de moyens que cette loi pénitentiaire de
compte tenu de la situation budgétaire
de notre pays et malgré des engagements
de Madame la Ministre qui
a largement insisté là-dessus encore ce
matin je suis pas persuadé que ça va
être le cas parce que nous ne le
pourrons pas enfin permettez-moi juste
quand même avant de terminer de me
féliciter de quelque chose c'est de
l'aband de l'abandon en CMP de l'article
8 ter dans sa rédaction
issue du Sénat sur proposition du
rapporteur qui faisait de la contrainte
pénale une peine autonome avant d'en
arriver là il me semble en effet
nécessaire que puisse être fourni les
conclusions de la mission cotes dont
madame la ministre a rappelé ce matin
l'importance sur l'échelle des peines la
hiérarchie des peines et dès lors il
faut se féliciter que en CMP un délai de
deux ans ait été décidé pour soumettre
un Parlement au Parlement un rapport à
cet égard ça me paraît une excellente
chose je le répète moi je me félicite de
cette nouvelle rédaction de cet article
8h
mais ça ne va pas m'empêcher j'ai
commencé par la je termine par là de
voter contre ce texte
je ne vois pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de vote
je vais donc mettre au voile l'ensemble
du projet de loi dans la rédaction
résultant du texte proposé par la
Commission mix paritaire modifiée par
les amendements du Gouvernement dont
l'intitulé est désormais ainsi rédigé
projet de loi relatif à
l'individualisation des peines et
renforçant l'efficacité des sanctions
pénales
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient le projet de loi est
définitivement adopté
voilà pour l'examen des conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur la
réforme pénale vous pourrez la revoir à
tout moment sur notre site public
sénat.fr très belle journée à tous sur
notre chaîne
aux Antilles c'est le scandale le plus
retentissant des dix dernières années